GOOD AFTERNOON
I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
TO THE FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE COMMITTEE MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE NOT
WITH COMMITTEE ARE AT THIS TIME
WE DO NOT HAVE QUORUM SO I'M
GONNA CALL FOR ALL MEMBERS BUT
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM AND
GIVEN HOW MUCH WORK WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF USI'D LIKE US TO
BEGIN. AS A SYMPTOMATIC- GOT A
NUMBER OF FIVE ANNOUNCEMENTS
I'M GONNA READ TO START ANA
THANK ALL THE STAFF WOULD MEAN
A RETURN TO THE CAPITOL
POSSIBLE DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE- AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON IN THIS
ROOM. ROSS REQUIREMENT MUST BE
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WHETHER
HERE IN THIS ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A MASK WE WILL PROVIDE ONE
TO YOU IT IS A CUSTOM. AND
PRACTICE OF THE HOUSE THE
MEMBERS BE PROPERLY ATTIRED
WHICH MEANS FOR PURPOSES OF
THIS HEARING. WEARING A MASK.
NOW WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA ONE BILLS ON CONSENT. I
WANT TO MENTION THAT- AB
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS AB SORRY ITEM
EIGHTEEN. WHICH IS AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WORKS. AS WELL AS
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR. HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM THE
AGENDA TODAY AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHORS THEY WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY. SINCE IT IS LATE
ON A THURSDAY AND MANY MEMBERS
NEED TO CATCH FLIGHTS TO GET
BACK TO THEIR DISTRICTS. WE
NEED TO MOVE EFFICIENTLY
THROUGH OUR GENDER. SO WE'RE
ASKING AUTHORS TO GIVE TO SYNC
PRESENTATIONS PARTICULARLY THE
BILL IS NONCOMMERCIAL
CONTROVERSIAL AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION TO BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN EARLY MOTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. EACH BILL CAN HAVE UP
TO ME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. EACH MAIN WITNESS
WILL GET UP TO TWO MINUTES. AND
THEN WE ARE TODAY LIMITING
PUBLIC COMMENT TO TOTAL OF TEN
MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT PER
BUILT. AND WILL HAVE ONE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD DURING WHICH
BOTH THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL SHOULD CALL IN AT
THE SAME TIME. TO REGISTER
THEIR POSITION ON A BILL.
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT FOR ALL
OTHER WITNESSES CONTENT TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WE ASK THAT YOU ONLY SAY. YOUR
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL IF
YOU SEE MORE THAN THAT WE WILL
ASK THE OPERATOR TO CUT YOU OFF.
IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE WEB PORTAL ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. THIS WILL
BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD OF THE BILL YOU CAN ALSO
SUBMIT AN EMAIL TO COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND THE LET ME JUST ARE.
SO- ONE ALSO MENTIONED THAT WE
ARE USING MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH A WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY TO BILLS THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
THE TELEVISION SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING THEM PLEASE DO
SO WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION AND IT IS POSSIBLE
FOR SEVERAL THESE ITEMS THAT
THE AUTHORS AGAIN GIVEN THE
TIME AND THE FACT THAT A LOT OF
MEMBERS ARE ARE TRYING TO GET
BACK TO THEIR DISTRICTS THE
DIFFERENT MEMBERS MAY BE
PRESENTING FOR THEM SO LISTEN
FOR THE BILL NUMBER. IF YOU ARE
CALLING THEM- AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE DO SO AS WHOEVER'S
PRESENTING THE BILL'S
TESTIFYING THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN QUEUE AND
IF YOUR CONTENT PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST IN ANY SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE THE MAIN
ONE IS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST ADULT YOU REMAIN ON A
LIVE LINE AND NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON
TO SPEAK IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL OUR
COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2085 MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP.
AND ALSO AGAIN WANT TO MENTION
THAT WE ARE STILL ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- AND- AGAIN
AS I SAID BEFORE WE WILL BE
LIMITING OUR TOTAL TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT PER BILL AT TEN
MINUTES AND APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING WITH
THAT WE STILL DO NOT HAVE COURT
SO I'M GONNA MOVE TO THE FIRST
ITEM IN THE FILE ORDER WHICH IS
FILE ITEM ONE AB. SIXTY EIGHT
MISTER SALAS WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK-
COULD MEMBERS YOU FOR STARTING
AS COMMITTEE IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME- FIRST LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING I. WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL. AB
SIXTY EIGHT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS MORE HAS
MORE EFFECTIVE APPROACH IN
ADDRESSING. THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS BY EXPANDING THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. OF HDDS
ANNUAL REPORTING PLAN AND
MODERNIZING THE STATEWIDE
HOUSING PLAN. AS YOU KNOW MR
CHAIRMAN I AM- THE CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT.
COMMITTEE AND I REQUEST AN
AUDIT OF THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. AB SIXTY EIGHT
WILL IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. TO REQUIRE MORE
INFORMATION IN THE STATE'S
HOUSING PLAN IN ORDER TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS. WITH THAT WOULD
YOU DO ESTABLISH WARNER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF.
MOTHER MODELING OF A SHORT
PRESENTATION- AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THERE IS NO WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OR WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- TO THE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES. TO ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AN OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN
YOUR MIKE IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER ALL WAR
ALL MEN ON BEHALF. CHECK. AND
WE HAVE MORE COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE
NUMBERS. THE LINE NINETY NINE
YOUR MIKE IS UP. LINE NINETY
NINE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE- THIS IS RECALL
WITH LIVABLE CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSING THE BILL THANK YOU.
ALIGNED ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
WE ARE MY KIDS UP. HI THIS IS
DAVID WHEATLEY AS AN INDIVIDUAL
OPPOSING THE BILL. THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOUR MY
KIDS UP. WE LOST ONE THIRTY
EIGHT- LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI MY
NAME IS HI MATT PALOS. MEMBER
LABOR THEN I LOOKED AT THREE
FORTY FIVE AND I'M GOING IN
THERE STATE BUILDING RIGHT. AND
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
FIFTEEN. THAT'S A DIFFERENT
BILL. I WANTED FOR A STATE THAT
THIS IS AB SIXTY EIGHT SO IF
YOU ARE COMING TO TESTIFY ABOUT
OTHER BILLS- THIS IS NOT THAT
BILLS OF AB SIXTY A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE THANK YOU. AN
ONLINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. FIVE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE HERE MY COULD
OPEN. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION. SEE NO DISCUSSION
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS IT'S
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE THE
MODELING OF A SHORT
PRESENTATION AND AS YOU KNOW-
ALSO JUST APPRECIATE YOU FOR
REQUESTING THE AUDIT THAT I
KNOW LED TO THIS BILL AND TO
LOOK FOR TO TAKE EMOTIONALLY OF
CORE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I DO
SEE THE ONLY OTHER MEMBERS THE
ROOM AT THIS POINT IS MR HOLDEN
WE WILL CALL FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
FIVE. TWELVE YOU'RE A LUCKY MAN
THE STOLEN. WELL PLAYED WELL I
DO APPRECIATE I KNOW THAT MR
BLOOM IS GOING TO TAKE UP SOME
OF YOUR TIME IS KIND ENOUGH TO
ALLOW ME TO JUMP THE LINE- BUT
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE- FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB FIVE TWELVE IT'S A BILL THAT
WILL GIVE TO CITIES IN MY
DISTRICT IT SOUNDS TO ADDRESS.
TWO PERSISTENT PROBLEMS THE
COST OF CONSTRUCTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THE IMPACT OF
CALTRANS AS A LANDLORD
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WILL
ALLOW PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
CHARITIES TO PURCHASE LAND
OWNED BY CALTRANS FOR THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE ONLY
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AT THE TIME
THAT YOU HAVE A QUORUM ASPERGER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I
MUCH MANDA WITHOUT WE GO TO
YOUR WITNESS. HER FILE ITEMS
SEVEN I SEE THERE IS NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO WE CAN GO TO THE
OPERATOR. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AGAIN THIS IS FOR FILE ITEM
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE. AND
IF YOU COULD OPEN UP THE LINES
AND AGAIN I REMIND THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO ONLY STATE
YOUR NAME. AND ORGANIZATION
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE SPEND.
ZERO AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS COMING FOR. YOU ARE
SETTING THE RECORD FOR THE
SHORTEST PRESENTATION ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THAT VOTE AT THE TIME THE
TYPICAL BACKYARD JUST KNOW FOR
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS A HAS
SIMILARITIES TO SB FIFTY ONE
BUTTERFLIES TO PASADENA SOUTH
PASADENA. I THINK IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THOSE TWO BILLS
WILL LIKELY BE NEED TO BE
RECONCILED IN THE FUTURE BUT
THAT WILL BE FOR A FUTURE TIME.
AND WITH THAT TO APPRECIATE
YOUR- PRESENTATION AND WE WILL
TAKE A MOTION ON THAT AT THE
PROPER TIME. MCGEORGE THANK YOU.
SO AT THIS TIME WE'RE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS SO I'M GOING TO ASK
MISS CREEK SILVA SHE WOULD LIKE
TO. SENATE FILE ITEM NINETEEN
WHICH IS AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY
SANTIAGO SAID THIS IS AGAIN.
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA PRESENTING FOR MR
SANTIAGO AB. THIRTEEN OH FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM. HAPPY TO BE
PRESENTING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUE MIGUEL SANTIAGO
AB THIRTEEN ZERO FOUR CLARIFIES
THE OBLIGATION OF PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING AND ALL
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT RELATED ACTIVITIES
THERE HAVE BEEN RECENT REPORTS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO HAVE
NOT. ADEQUATELY FULFILLED THEIR
AFS H. OBLIGATIONS TO ENSURE
ALL AGENCIES ARE AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR WILL CLARIFY
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST
ADDRESS RACIAL INTEGRATION AND
SEGREGATION PATTERNS AS WELL AS
FOR FAIR HOUSING ISSUES THIS
BILL ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ADDRESSING HOUSING ANYTHING
EQUITIES AND ACTIVELY PLANNING
FOR MORE INTEGRATED FUTURE THAT
PRIOR. PRIORITIZES FAIR HOUSING-
WITH THERE IS ONE WITNESS-
JOINING US VIA TELEPHONE- THIS
IS ANYA LOLZ LAWLER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT. FOR THE
OPERATOR COULD OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR MS LAWLER. TO THE OPERATOR.
IT MEDICARE WE ARE LOOKING FOR
THAT LINE RIGHT NOW. IT'S AN A
LAWLER. AND IF SHE'S NOT THERE
BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING OUT OF
ORDER WE CAN MOVE ON BUSINESS
LONGER. IT. YEAH I'M HERE
GREGORI THANK YOU ON. I GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ON THE LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
NATIONAL HOUSING LAW PROJECT
THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT- AND THE OTHER SPONSORS
OF THE BILL- FIRST THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF TELOMERIC BUILDER FOR
PINCH HITTING ON THE BILL
TODAY- AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. NO FOUR BUILD ON
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH REQUIRE
THAT PUBLIC ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING IN THEIR
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES- JUST
ADVOCATES OBLIGATION IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
GOVERNMENT AND EITHER ACTIVELY
WORKING TO DISMANTLE. I'M GOING
AN ENTRENCHED PATTERNS OF
SEGREGATION AND THE PLACE THAT
BROUGHT ON BY DECADES OF
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC ACTIONS THAT
LIMITED HOUSING CHOICE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND PEOPLE WITH LOW INCOME I'VE
HEARD THAT EVEN COUNTY IS MUCH
OF THE WORKABLE SIGN THE APP OF
ITS OBLIGATIONS STARTS WITH THE
PREPARATION OF THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT- AS THAT WORK IS ROLLED
OUT SINCE THE ADOPTION OF AB
SIXTY TWO THANKS WE'VE NOTICED
THE NEED FOR CLARIFICATION TO
ENSURE THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES
KNOW. WHAT IT MEANS TO
MEANINGFULLY ANALYZE YOUR
HOUSING ISSUES IN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND TAKE CONCRETE
ACTION TO REMEDY THEM THE BILL
MAKES A CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
HOPEFULLY PUT- CALIFORNIA ON A
PATH TO A MORE FAIR HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL- AND WE.
LOOK AT YOUR SUPPORT THANK. AND
WITHOUT I THINK THIS LAW ZERO-
WITNESS OTHER IS NO. WITNESSES
TO THE UPPER IF YOU COULD OPEN
UP THE LINES. FOR ANYONE.
WISHING TO SPEAK PUBLIC COM AND-
OR OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTEEN
OH FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE. ACTUALLY WE
CAN WE HAVE SOMEONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SO I'D LIKE TO
KNOWLEDGE OF. JUST MARCH
DIVERSE THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU MR STAMMERS BACK TO THE
LINES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU OULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. OKAY AN
OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED TEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT. AN ONLINE
ONE HUNDRED FORTY YOU'RE MY
DEVELOPMENT. YOU KNOW WHY IT
WAS A COMPANY HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. OF. LINE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS IS
JACKIE VERY WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI MY
NINE ONE UNRESOLVED. WITH
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS KNOWLEDGE TRADE AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
CURRENTLY NOT OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE FIFTEEN. TO AN ONLINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YOUR MIKE
IS UP. YEAH WHAT QUESTIONS ARE
LONG POVERTY I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
THEREFORE THANK YOU. IN LIGHT
ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HEY DAVID WHEATLEY-
CALLING TO OPPOSE AND ASKING
FOR MORE TIME TO SPEAK THE
ORGANIZED PEOPLE'S
ORGANIZATIONS GET MORE WEIGHT
NOT FAIR. AND ALIGN NINETY TO
HEAR MY COULD OPEN. MY NAME IS
MANDY CAMARO I'M WITH MONTEREY
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
OPPOSED TO AB ONE ONE FIVE BUT
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES I
WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR WE
ARE NOT TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS MOMENT AB ONE ONE FIVE.
THIS IS AB ONE THREE OH FOR ITS
FILE ITEM NINETEEN BACK TO THE
OPERATOR. AN ONLINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT- MY COULD OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MAIL. AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. IN A LIGHT ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. WHICH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN
INSTITUTE WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR.
AND WE HAD WE DO HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH ONLINE
COOPER. AND THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY YOUR MIKE IT UP.
HI THIS IS LINDA FROM ALSO WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE SO WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR- AND ARE CO SPONSORS
THANK YOU. AND LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI
THIS IS JACKIE WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA I MAY HAVE
ACCIDENTALLY SENT- ONE FIFTEEN
BUT HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN OH FOUR
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WITH SIR
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
FOR THEIR- TARGET SUPPORT OF
THIS ISSUE OVER THE YEARS- WE
ALL KNOW THIS YEAR'S REVEALED-
THE VETS- SOMETHING WE HAVE
BEEN VERY WHERE FOR MANY YEARS
WHICH IS. THAT PASSED HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION HAS BEEN SO DEEP
AND PERVASIVE THAT SIMPLY ENDED
DISCRIMINATION TO LOW INCOME
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS NOT
ENOUGH WE NEED TO
AFFIRMATIVELY. UNDO THE DAMAGE
THIS BILL WOULD CONTINUE MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION AND FOR THAT
REASON HAS MY SUPPORT. YES THE-
MS CLARK SILVA FEE OF ANY FINAL
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR. JUST SO I KNOW THE
AUTHOR WOULD APPRECIATE AN AYE
VOTE GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE LET'S FIRST ESTABLISH
A QUORUM OF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO HEAR.
FIASCO HERE SACHITH GABRIELLE.
THANK YOU HERE FULLER UP. OVER
HERE KILEY. HIGHLY HERE
MAIENSCHEIN THANKS SILVA IF
THEY'RE WEEKS. WE HAVE FOUR
ANSWERS REFORM AND- WITHOUT
COULD I ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
MOVE AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR.
THERE'S MOTIONS ARE SECOND. AND
THE MODEM UNLESS THERE'S ANY
CONVERSATION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI TWO
FIVE EIGHT. NOT REALLY. YEAH HI
GABRIEL I KALRA. FULLER I
HIGHLY. MAIENSCHEIN KIRK SILVA
I. FEEL THAT I WICKS. FOR FOUR
FOUR TWO ZERO SAN SALVADOR HAS
FOUR VOTES WE NEED ONE MORE
VOTE TO MOVE IT FORWARD AND
LET'S DO A LITTLE BIT OF
HOUSEKEEPING AT THIS POINT TO
GO TO THE CONSENT AGENDA COULD
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE FOR FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. FOR THE MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTIONS TO FASTER THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
TRUE FEW HEIGHTS THEY ARE CO HI
BY GABRIEL. CHOLERA. KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
KIRK SILVA FIVE SIX SILVA I
WEEKS. FOR ONE SIX SIX TWO ZERO
ZERO NUMBER PASSED MEMBERS ONLY
LET'S GO THROUGH THE ITEMS
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD SO WE CAN
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND FILE
ITEM ONE AB SIXTY EIGHT SALAS
CORROSION PLEASE. THERE'S A
MOTION IS OUR SECOND. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO ONE TWO I
SAY ARE DOPE NOT MOVING. BOEING
CAPRIO APRIL KALRA. ALL RIGHT
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN KIRK SILVA
HI THANKS YOU BYE WEEKS. FOUR
TWO ZERO SEVEN OCTOBER IS FOUR
ZERO WILL WAIT FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND ONE OUT
WE FIND THAT WE WANNA GET
EMOTIONAL IS FILE ITEM SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE. HOLDEN. OUR
PROMOTION TO MOVE THAT FORWARD.
THERE'S A CAN. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
MOTION OF A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY MOTION TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TROOP BY FEW I'D
SAY OUR GOAL HI THERE I
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I'D KALRA.
ALL RIGHT I KILEY. HI I MAIN
SHOW COOKS. HI FOR SILVA I
WEEKS. TO SEE TWO ZERO SIR THE
BILL PASSES OUT OF ARGUMENT WAS
SIX WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR APPS MEMBERS AND WITH LET
US TOWARD A BILL PRESS FILE
ITEMS. AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT S.
MEMBER YOUR TO DO. WELCOME I
THINK THIS IS YOUR FIRST TIME
AND FOR THIS COMMITTEE I AM
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS. THE UNMET NEEDS OF
CHALLENGES TO HOUSING THE
HOMELESS. INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
PETS ESPECIALLY DURING
EMERGENCIES LIKE COCA NINETEEN
PADERA. A PET IS A SOURCE OF
COVERAGE STRENGTH AND LOVE FOR
SOMEONE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST HOMELESS
SHELTERS HAVE NO PET POLICY
WHICH IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS THAT KEEP HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AWAY FROM THEIR
SHELTERS. LEADING MANY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO REMAIN OUT OF
THIS REMAIN OUT IN THE STREETS.
AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT WILL REQUIRE
ANY STATE FUND FUNDED IN TRUMP
HOUSING OR SHELTER. TO FOLLOW
THE LOW BARRIER NEXT NAVIGATION
CENTER MODEL WHICH WILL WHICH
WILL REMOVE BARRIERS TO ENTER.
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AB TWO
FIFTY EIGHT WILL ALSO ENCOURAGE
SHELTERS TO PARTNER WITH. WITH
ANY OTHER LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAY BE ABLE
TO KEEP THE- KEEP. HELPING
PROVIDE FOOD AND OTHER
VETERINARIAN SERVICES IN ORDER
TO SHELTERS THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR PATHS
pCHRISTOPHER MARTIN WITH POLICY
DIRECTOR AND HOMELESS- HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND JILL ANTHONY
CRUZ HERE IN THE AUDIENCE. THE
DIRECTOR OF- AT THE ANIMAL
PROTECTION LEAGUE TO REVISED
TESTIMONY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SOMEONE NUMBER LASSEN
MISS ANTHONY IF YOU WANT TO
STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE. AND
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHECK TO AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND HOUSING OF
THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VILLA PUT OFF.
MY NAME IS GIANT JEANNIE AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF DEVELOPMENT
AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH FOR THE
ANIMAL PROTECTION LEAGUE. AND
BASED OUT OF STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA AND SERVING SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. I AM HERE TODAY
IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. THIS BILL WAS WRITTEN
AND IS ENDORSED WITH LOVE TEARS
AND FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCES FROM
WORKING IN THE TRENCHES
ALONGSIDE AND HOUSED AND THEIR
PETS. IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
IN THE BEGINNING STAGES OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC I WAS INVITED
TO COME ASSESS THE CONDITION OF
SOME ANIMALS OUT AT THE
HOMELESS CAMP. TODAY I HAVE
BEEN VISITING THESE CAMPS UP TO
FIVE TIMES A WEEK EVERY WEEK.
EVERSENSE DURING THIS LAST YEAR
THE CONDITIONS I HAVE WITNESSED
FOR BOTH PEOPLE AND PETS ARE
UTTERLY FORMIDABLE. I HAVE
WATCHED THE NUMBER OF HOMES
CONTINUE TO GROW RIGHT ALONG
WITH THEIR FURRY COMPANIONS. AT
A NUMBER THAT DEFIES
COMPREHENSION. DESPERATE FOR
CHANGE THE ANIMAL PROTECTION
LEAGUE AND THE STOCKTON
HOMELESS SHELTER AND FUNDED BY
THE UNITED WAY AND THE CITY OF
STOCKTON. INNER TOGETHER
CREATING A PILOT PROGRAM. THIS
PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWED THE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL TO BE
ACCOMPANIED BY ONE PET. INTO A
LOW BARRIER SHELTER AND THE
ANIMAL PROTECTION LEAGUE
PROVIDED FOOD. A NEW KENNEL
EMBED WE SPAYED AND NEUTERED
VACCINATION. AND ANY ADDITIONAL
VETERINARY NEEDED. BY THURSDAY
AT THE HOMELESS SHELTER. THIS
PILOT PROGRAM HAS ENABLED
PEOPLE AND THEIR PETS TO BE IN
A STABLE ENVIRONMENT. AND IT
HAS EVEN OPENED THE DOOR. FOR
THE HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL TO SEEK
EMPLOYMENT FOR EXAMPLE MY NEW
FRIEND VERONICA WAS ABLE TO
START HER NEW LIFE BECAUSE OF
THE START OF THE PROGRAM. FOR
ANNIKA HAS REUNITED WITH HER
FAMILY AND SPENDS HER DAY
TURNING AND JOB APPLICATIONS.
WITH THE PEACE OF MIND THAT HER
BELONGINGS ARE NOT BEING STOLEN
AND HER DOG ROXY IS SAFE AT
HOME. HOW MUCH SHELTERS AND
LOCAL ANIMAL NONPROFITS ACROSS
THE STATE CAN RECREATE THE SAME
OUTCOME. AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT
WILL REQUIRE THAT ALL STATE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. THAT FUND IN TERM.
INTERIM HOUSING TO FOLLOW LOW
BARRIER HOUSING FIRST PRACTICES
WHICH WILL REMOVE THE BARRIERS
MANY. HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS FACE
WHEN ACCESSING SHELTER. I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHILLIP WOULD ROCK. FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION I PROUDLY
SUPPORT AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT. AND
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK
MISTER FOR MISTER CHRIS MARTIN
FROM HOUSING CALIFORNIA TO
TESTIFY. IN MR MARTIN'S LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER
MARTIN AND I'M THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AN ADVOCACY NONPROFIT FOCUSED
ON ENSURING ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO A SAFE STABLE
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS WITH OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND OF WHICH ARE
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. TOTALING OVER
HALF OF OUR NATION'S
UNSHELTERED POPULATION.
RESPONDING EFFECTIVELY TO
HOMELESSNESS REQUIRES A
COMBINATION OF STRATEGY
PREVENTING OR DIVERTING PEOPLE
FROM EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE ENSURING
PEOPLE TRANSITION RAPIDLY FROM
HOMELESSNESS TO HOUSING AND
SERVICES. AND PROVIDING
IMMEDIATE LOW BARRIER SHELTER
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHO CANNOT
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS PERMANENT
HOUSING. I'M MERGING TO SHELTER
SHOULD SUPPORT FLOW FROM
HOUSING CRISIS TO A HOUSING
STABILITY. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
HIGH BARRIERS TO ENTRY TO
EMERGENCY SHELTER OR INTERIM
HOUSING PROHIBIT THE FLOW.
THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND ACT AS
THE SERVICES. I'VE GOT PERCEIVE
THAT AN EMERGENCY SAY REQUIRES
CONFORMING TO ARBITRARY RULES
OR EXPECTATIONS THAT SEEM
UNREASONABLE PUNITIVE OR THAT
DIVIDE THEM FROM THERE TO FIND
FAMILY THEY MADE TO KLEIN
SUPPORT THEY THEY URGENTLY
NEED. FOR EMERGENCY SHELTER TO
ACHIEVE ITS INTENDED PURPOSE OF
THE EXPECTATION PLAY THANK GOD
SHOULD BE MINIMAL TRANSPARENT
AND REASONABLE LOW BARRIER
SHELTERS EMPHASIZED WELCOMING
GOT IN AS THEY ARE WELL HAVING
CLEAR AND SIMPLE BEHAVIORAL
EXPECTATIONS THAT APPLY TO
ANYONE RESIDING IN THE SHELTER.
THESE EXPECTATIONS ARE NARROWLY
FOCUSED ON MAINTAINING A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL THIS MODEL
IS KNOWN AS THE NAVIGATION
CENTER MY- AT THE NAVIGATION.
CALLING ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE
PETS LIVE WITH A PARTNER STORE
THEIR PROPERTY AND COMING UP
REALLY IN ADDITION THE CENTER
OFFERS ROUND THE CLOCK CASE
MANAGEMENT. MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
CONNECTIONS THE BENEFIT
PROGRAMS AND HOUSING ALL IN ONE
LOCATION. REQUIRING
PARTICIPANTS ARE RECIPIENTS OF
STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS TO
FOLLOW THE LOW BARRIER MODEL.
EIGHTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT WILL
CREATE A SYSTEM FOR ALL
REGARDLESS OF PRECONDITION AND
PROVIDE THEM ACT THAT THE
SHELTER ON THEIR WAY TOWARDS
FINDING STABILITY IN PERMANENT
HOUSING. WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR PROPOSING
THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION WHICH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS PROUD OF
THE POOR AND WE ARE JOB. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO
LET'S GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
INDIVIDUALS. THAT WISH TO SPEAK
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO FILE ITEM SIX AB. TWO FIVE
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. IN LINE ONE
HUNDRED TEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. CHURN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
TWO YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. SURE
MEMBERS GRANT MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HI DAVID WHITLEY-
THIS IS NOT PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
IS SOME SORT OF CHECKLIST THAT
THE HIGH BARRIER AND WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE PLEASE
GIVE US TIME. I'M GONNA ASK
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FLIGHT
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE- AND I WILL
ASK THE OPERATOR TO KIND OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE. NOT GOING
BEYOND THAT TO THE OPERATOR.
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
YOUR MIKE IT'S OPEN. ONE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE YOUR MY
KIDS UP. LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINETY- MY COULD OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ELIZABETH NOW
RESULT AND I AM C. E. O. OF
SHELTER MATTERS FOR PETS I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. AND MEDICARE THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
CONVERSATION. I WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS FOR WE
ALL KNOW THAT ONE SHELTERS
OFFER LOW BARRIER OPTIONS OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO COME INDOORS. THIS
BILL WILL HELP MAKE THESE
POLICIES REQUIREMENT FOR
VARIOUS TYPES OF INCREDIBLY
NECESSARY HOUSING AND- ENJOYS A.
TO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION TO THE TO ANNIE
PHAM FROM OTHER. YEAH- BIGAMIST
JERRY AND. WE NEED TO STEP UP
AND REMOVE THESE BEARS A. B.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT WILL DO THAT.
REMOVING THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY
WILL BE THE STE A STRONG STE BY
STEP TOWARDS. MOVING
CALIFORNIA- FORWARD. AND
ADDRESSING ALL THE HOMELESS IS
A CRISIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
WITH THIS BILL. HAS BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN FIDUCIARY. FEW HI TWO
FIVE THEY ARE TOO HIGH YEAH HI
GABRIELLE. YOUR BILL I KALRA. I
RIGHTS KILEY HIGHLY I MAY.
QUICKSILVER KIRKSVILLE THAT I
WEEKS. FIVE SIX TWO ZERO SAN
YOUR BILL PASSES AND ALLOW
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
WITHOUT A LET'S GO TO FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE
MISTER MAYES WELCOME. MISTER
CHAIR- AND MEMBERS. THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED AB FIVE
SEVENTY ONE- THIS LEGISLATION
IS JUST ONE SMALL PIECE IN A
LARGER PUSH TO MAKE HOUSING
MORE AFFORDABLE IN CALIFORNIA.
IMPACT AND DEVELOPMENT FEES
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT THE OVERALL
COST OF THE PROJECT AND ARE
OFTEN PASSED ALONG TO BUYERS IN
THE FORM OF HIGHER- HOME
PRICES. HOWEVER WHEN THESE FEES
ARE REQUIRED FOR AFFORDABLE
BONUS LAWS THE ENTIRE COST OF
THE PROJECT GOES UP UNLESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GETS BUILT.
THAT IS WHY MY LEGISLATION
SIMPLY PROHIBITS IMPOSING
CERTAIN FEES FOR DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE UNITS IT
SIMPLY DOES NOT MAKE SENSE TO
DISINCENTIVE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS WITHIN A DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATION AS WE SEEK TO
ENCOURAGE DEVELOPERS. TO
MAXIMIZE AFFORDABLE UNITS. I
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
JENNIFER'S BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION REALTORS
TO TESTIFY SUPPORT. IF WE GO TO
THE OPERATOR- TO ALLOW JENNIFER
STRUCK FROM THE REALTORS TO
TESTIFY PLACE. SHARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPECK ON
THE MAP ITSELF OR NO SUFFICIENT
REALTORS CROP BONTA THE BABY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE THREE WHICH
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE PROVING
HOUSING PERMITS CONTINUE TO
TREND DOWNWARD. CALIFORNIA
APPROVED A HUNDRED AND TWO
THOUSAND A NEW HOUSING UNITS IN
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH WAS A
DECREASE OF ALMOST 9% OF A
CONSTRUCTION UNITS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. EVEN MORE TROUBLING
THE NUMBER OF NEW MULTI FAMILY
UNITS PERMITTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY DROPPED ALMOST NINETEEN
PERCENT. EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE SIX TO CREATE MORE UNITS OF
NATURALLY OCCURRING AFFORDABLE
MARKET RATE HOUSING WHILE ALSO
SEEKING TO INCREASE AND
MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE UNITS.
CONTAINED WITHIN A DENSITY
BONUS APPLICATIONS BY REMOVING
THE DEFINITIVE FEES PLACED ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
CONTAINED WITHIN APPLICATION
DEVELOPERS CAN MAXIMIZE THE
TOTAL NUMBER. OF UNITS THAT
THEY ARE DEVELOPING. IT'S
SIMPLY THE MAKE SENSE OR FOR
HOUSING FUND HOW IF WE WILL
AMERICA THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS CONSTRUCTED.
AND MIXED INCOME DENSITY BONUS
PROJECTS. ARE MOVING OF PEOPLE
COULD BE WILL OF THE FROM THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AS WE SPEAK TO
ENACT POLICIES. TO HELP US
SOLVE OUR STATE PERSISTENT
CONTINUING HOUSING CRISIS. WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR ABOUT. AND WITH
THAT THERE. NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
THANK THE MAN AGAIN ONE. THEN
ZERO AND THIS IS FOR PHYLON
EIGHT A. B. FIVE SEVEN ONE
MAYES. LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR YEAR MIKE IS UP AT. SHARE
NUMBERS OUT SHORT THE TRAGEDY.
HAPPENED BE HOW THE ACTION
COALITION PROGRESS ON. THE PART
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO WE ARE MIKE IT UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS OF
THE MODERN THAT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
TMG PARTNERS AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION FOR
INFORMED ABOUT THANK YOU. FOR
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. DAVID WHEATLEY AS
AN INDIVIDUAL IN OPPOSITION.
LINE NINETY NINE YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. LINE NINETY NINE YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
RECALL WITH LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. BLIND TWO HUNDRED FIVE
HERE MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS BOB NAYLOR FOR FEELS DEAD
AND COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVEN
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN. BY OUR
MOBILE TRAVIS AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE DAIRY COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT AND SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY. FIVE THIRTY ONE. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED SIX YOUR MIKE IS UP.
HI KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. ONE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR YOUR MY GET UP. MISTER
JERRY NUMBERS AREN'T ABLE AND
GET REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS UP. BLIND
TWO HUNDRED SEVEN YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU LET'S NOT BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION. HAS BEEN MOTION OF
THE BILLS ARE SECOND THERE'S A
SECOND ANY FINAL COMMENTS BY
THE AUTHOR. ALL THINGS JERRY
JUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTIONS TO PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TROOPS. ARE TOO HIGH
THEY ARE DON'T HI. HI GABRIEL.
THE REAL LIFE KALRA. ALL RIGHT
KILEY HIGHLY I'M MAIN SHOW
QUICK SILVA. THANKS BYE WEEKS.
SIX ZERO SAN BILL PASSES. AND
WITH THAT I'LL BE PRESENTING-
OF MISCREANTS BILL SHORTLY- AND
MR GABRIEL'S ON THIS COMMITTEES
I'M GONNA ASK IF WE COULD GO TO
FOLLOWING THIRTEEN BECAUSE WE
HAVE IS BOERNER HORVATH HERE.
AB. EIGHT OH THREE. GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE IN THE MONTH AND
I'D REALLY LIKE TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE FRUIT.
LAW ALL HARD WORK ON THIS BILL-
TO GET IT TO BE ABLE TO BE
PRESENTED TODAY AND WITH THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION OF DO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS. TO
ADDRESS THE SAY ONE HOUSING
CRISIS WE NEED TO HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX. AB EIGHT
OH THREE THE STARTER HOME
REVITALIZATION AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AS A NEW TOOL TO
GET MORE MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING. BY ENCOURAGING MORE
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN HOMES. AB
EIGHT OH THREE IS REALLY VERY
SIMPLE. IT SAYS OF A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS GENERAL PLAN
DENSITY FOR CITI'S MATT. THE
MINIMUM LOT SO I CAN BECAUSE
LIKE LOT SIZE CAN BE WAIVED.
THIS ENABLES ZERO LOT LINE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ON MID
RANGE DENSITY SITES. THIS WILL
AVOID COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
CONDO MAPPING AS WELL AS VERY
AVOID VERY HIGH H. AWAY FEES.
WHICH ARE OFTEN NORTH OF OVER
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH IN
MY DISTRICT. AS A CASE STUDY
FOR THE LOS ANGELES SMALLER
ORDINANCE OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO SHOW. SMALL HOME LOT
DEVELOPMENT. ARE FEE SIMPLE
UNITS THAT INCREASE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
WERE WORKING WITH EXISTING LAND
USE DESIGNATIONS. THE MAXIMUM
SIZE OF A DEVELOPMENT UNDER AB
EIGHT OH THREE. IS FIVE ACRES
THERE IS A IS A TOTAL SQUARE
FOOTAGE- LIMIT ON THE SITE- ON
THE HOUSING. MAKING IT MORE
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN. AND IT'S
A PERFECT OPTION FOR
RESIDENTIAL INFO IN SUBURBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE
SURROUNDED BY. SINGLE FAMILY
LOWER DENSITY HOME. VERY
COMPATIBLE WITH COMMUNITY
CHARACTER. EIGHTY EIGHT OH
THREE IS TO IS TO PROVIDE A
MOTHER AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN
OPTIONS IN THE HOUSING MARKET
WHERE FAMILIES CAN BY. A SMALL
HOME AS A STARTER HOME IF ANY
OF YOU HAVE HIGHLAND VALUE
SUBURBAN. AREAS IN YOUR
DISTRICTS YOU'LL KNOW THERE ARE
NOT STARTER HOMES ANYMORE LIKE
OUR PARENTS HAD. SO THIS ALLOWS
FOR THEM TO BUY IN AND THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. AND WE KNOW
THAT BY ENCOURAGING HOME
OWNERSHIP WE'RE INCREASING THE
RESILIENCY OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE. DETERMINE A LOT SIZES
CURRENT MIDDLE DENSITY MULTI
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL ZONING
DISINCENTIVE WAS THE CREATION.
OF ENTRY LEVEL FEE SIMPLE ZERO
LOT LINE DETACHED HOMES. IN
AREAS THAT ALREADY ALLOW HIGHER
MEDIUM MID RANGED IN CITIES. IN
ADDITION AB EIGHT OH THREE SO
YOU'LL APPRECIATE THAT I HOPE
ON THE COMMITTEE. DOES NOT
REDUCE THE PARKING STANDARDS
BUT DOES NOT REMEMBER REQUIRE
US TO BUILD HOUSES FOR CARS.
ANOTHER WAY THAT AB A THREE MEG
STARTER HOMES MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR THOSE STARTING OUT IN THE
HOUSING MARKET. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE TODAY. AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW- OTHERS WHO WORK
WITH ME ON THE PHONE HEARD
ABOUT THIS BILL OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS. MY FRIEND BRETT
FOR A LOCAL ARCHITECT AND I
WROTE THIS BILL TOGETHER. SO
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS BRIGHT PHARAOH-
OKAY THIS COMMON SHORTCOMING OF
THE COMMITTEE HAS. A VERY LONG
AGENDA TODAY- SO. I WOULD TURN
OVER TO BRETT FARRELL. TO THE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU SO THE
NUMBER OF. GO AHEAD PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY THANK YOU MY
NAME IS BRETT FERRO- AN
ARCHITECT IN DESIGNING BUILDING
AND DEVELOPING. THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO AND AT LOCATIONS AND- I
BASICALLY AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH IS NOT THE ONLY ONE TO
HAVE. YES THE OTHER ONE COULD
WE WERE SCHEDULED LATER FOR THE
DAY STUFF OKAY. THERE IS A ONE
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
CALL ON MR BROWN ACOSTA FROM
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FUND. PARTITION.
RIGHT I GOT THAT LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS BRIAN AUGUSTA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND ALSO
CONTAINS COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF
OUR COLLEAGUES AT WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
BASED ON THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS MR ANALYSIS AND OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEMBER AND
OUR STAFF WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ONCE WE
SEE THOSE AMENDMENTS AND PRINT
SOMETHING CUTE TO THE AUTHOR.
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE NATION'S.
THANK YOU I'LL LET US NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN. THIS CHAMBER
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY. LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S AN WHEN THE
REMOTE STATIONS THAT WISH TO
TESTIFY. N. C. NINE LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ASK FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB EIGHT OH THREE
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT OH THREE PLEASE
pPRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
LINE TWO HUNDRED TWELVE YEAR
MIKE IS UP. JENNIFER ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS YOUR IMPORTANT. AN
ONLINE NINETY NINE YEAR MIKE IS
UP. RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. AND LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOUR MIKE IS
UP. DAVID WHEATLEY AN
INDIVIDUAL OPPOSED. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME THANK YOU
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS MS CLARK SILVA- EAT.
YES I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
CREATIVE BILL FORWARD I
PARTICULARLY LIKE IT AS WAS
NOTED WE NEED TO HAVE ALL TYPES
OF OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO US AS
WE LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE OF
HOUSING- WHETHER THAT BE- THE
STANDARD SIZE IN A SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD WHETHER IT
BE- A SMALLER SIZE. AND EVEN
AND- LOOKING AT PROPERTY AND
HOW WE USE OUR CURRENT LOTS AND-
WAYS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN USED IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS NOT ONLY
DO I SUPPORT THIS- BUT I THINK
A VERY WELL DONE THANK YOU. AND
MOVE THE BILL THE MOTION OF THE
BILLS ARE SECOND SECOND ARE
MISTER KALRA THANK YOU JUST
REASONS SURE NO I THINK THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
IS AN AND THE OPPOSITION THAT
NOW WILL BE MOVING OPPOSITION
TO THEIR CONCERNS- ABOUT IT IS
VERY CHALLENGING TO BUILD SOME
OF THAT IN THE VERY LOW INITIAL
INCOME PERSON TALKING FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT AND THE
COMMITTEE STOP WORKING WITH ALL
PARTIES. TO MAKE SURE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
HELLO THIS. I WANT THANK THE ON
FOR CREATES AND HER. AS WELL AS
HER DEEP ENGAGEMENT WITH MY
STAFF I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
STAFF. FOR WORKING ON THIS AND-
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTING. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
AND FOR UNDERSTANDING. ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF GUARDRAILS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CREATION OF
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
DOESN'T COME AT THE EXPENSE OF
LOW INCOME HOUSING. WE ALL KNOW
WE NEED BOTH AND THERE WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS AND HAPPY TO
MOVE THIS BILL FOR. AND LET ME
ASK THE AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WITHOUT
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND MODEM SECRETARY. MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TROOPS. FIVE FEW
ALLIES C. R. COSTA. HI SAY ART
BY GABRIEL. GABRIEL I'D KALRA.
ALL RIGHT KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
KIRK SILVA HI MARK SILVA I
WEEKS. TO THE CITY- FIVE ZERO
ZERO YOUR BILL PASSES I'M GLAD
IT'S OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND-
WE WILL WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO- TO ADD ON I MEAN THAT
RESPECTFULLY. AND WITH THAT
WHEN WE GO TO OUR NEXT ITEM
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB EIGHT
THIRTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO I
READ AN ARTICLE IN A LATEST.
ABOUT SOME CHILDREN WHO HAD
DIED IN A IN A FIRE IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING. AND THE
REASON THERE WAS A FIRE IS
BECAUSE THE APARTMENT COMPLEX.
WAS REALLY IN AGREE JUST
CONDITION SUB HABITABLE. AND
DIDN'T HAVE HE TOO DIDN'T HAVE-
IT HAD A LOT OF DR- DRY ROT AND
MOLD BLACK MOLD IN THE BUILDING
IT WAS IT WAS A SLUM. AND THE
REASON THAT THIS BUILDING WAS
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE LIKE THIS
IS BECAUSE THE CODE ENFORCEMENT
ENTITY IN THIS PARTICULAR CITY.
REFUSED TO GO INSPECT WERE IN
FORCE. ON THE LANDLORD BECAUSE
THEY HAD SET UP A WHOLE BUNCH
OF CRITERIA THAT THE TENANTS
HAD TO GO THROUGH INTO THEIR
ORDINANCE IN ORDER TO GET THE
CODE ENFORCEMENT. THE TENANTS
FOR INSTANCE HAD TO BE UP ON
THEIR RENT EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A
SUB HABITABLE BUILDING. SOME OF
THE TENANTS RUN DOCUMENTED THEY
WERE AFRAID PROBABLY THREATENED
BY THE LANDLORD OF BEING
EVICTED OR TURNED OVER TO ICE
IF THEY WERE TO COMPLAIN. WELL
I WAS REALLY SHOCKED I MEAN BUT
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT MY CITY'S
CODE ENFORCEMENT ACTUALLY. TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
BUILDINGS WERE HABITABLE
REGARDLESS OF THE TENANTS OF
THE STATUS OF THE TENANTS. I
FOUND OUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND AB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT SIX TO CHANGE THAT
AN IT SAYS SIMPLY THAT CODE
ENFORCEMENT IN LOCALITIES NEED
TO ENFORCE. NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE BUILDINGS IN THEIR
DISTRICTS ARE MEET BASIC SAFETY
AND HEALTH STANDARDS. THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL DOES IT'S
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY SIMPLE BUT
VERY IMPORTANT FOR VULNERABLE
TENANTS. WHO ARE OTHERWISE- IT
TIMES AFRAID TO GO DIRECTLY TO
LANDLORDS THEY SHOULD HAVE
ANOTHER OUT. IF THEY'RE SCARED
OF THEIR LANDLORD THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GO TO A CITY AND
SAY. MY BUILDING DOESN'T. HAVE
RUNNING WATER DOESN'T HAVE HEAT.
PLEASE MAKE THE LAND BRING THIS
BUILDING UP TO CODE. I WITH
THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND I THINK THAT
WE DO HAVE. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- FROM WE HAVE CYNTHIA
CALVILLO FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
BRIAN ACOSTA FROM CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES. THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
AND- LET US NOW GO TO THE MAIN
WITNESSES TO THE OPERATOR IF WE
COULD ACKNOWLEDGMENTS CYNTHIA
CASTEEL. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
MEMBERS YOU CAN'T BE A WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HERE IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE WHICH WE ARE
PROUD BECAUSE AUTHOR. EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE INSURE TENNESSEE
CROSS THE STATE REQUIREMENTS
SECTION OF HOME IN RESPONSE TO
A DEFICIENCY WITHOUT HAVING
INAPPROPRIATE CONDITIONS CLICK
ON THE RIGHT. ACTION I THE
STATE'S LARGEST AND OLDEST
SUPPORT CENTER WE HEAR FROM
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE REPRESENT LOW INCOME
RENTERS. SOMETIME THINK
BARRIERS WHEN ASKING FOR AN
INSPECTION TO HABITABILITY
COMPLAINT. I SIGNED. UP FOR AN
INSPECTOR COMMISSION A HOUSING
ESTATE THAT THEY MUST JUMP
THROUGH. HOOPS FOR AN INFECTION
TO OCCUR. CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
IMPOSES UNIFORM. ON ALL LAND.
CAN THE HUMAN PROPERTY THREE
FROM THE FACT THAT SEPTEMBER
MAULED THE FACT WIRING. IN THE
LIGHT. ENSURING PUBLIC A FORMAT
UNIVERSE EXPECT. EVERY DAY KIND
OF THE MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
WORK TOGETHER QUICKLY TO A
DRUNKEN. THE ONE THAT THE CASE
BECAUSE- ACTUALLY BECAUSE
RECOVER TO FIND PENALTY THAT. I
THAT ACTUALLY. WERE TO RENT
BIOLASE. THIS DOES NOT BAN ON.
RELIABLE GOVERNMENT ABOUT MY
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE IS THE THING
UP WITH ARE. EIGHT THREE
PROVIDE THE FACT THAT WE'RE OF
THE WORST COULD BARELY AMONG.
LANDMARK THE STATE AND EVERY
LOCAL. HAPPENING FINANCIAL WHEN
WE'RE MEETINGS I. AND YOU KNOW
ALLOWED PROP TO DETERIORATE AS
WE WORK ALL OF OUR GOING RIGHT
AND I COULD HEALTHCARE. EIGHT
EIGHT BRING IN THE COMING FROM
THE THAT WE THAT WE ENSURE TO
ARE OF. EQUAL RIGHTS AND THE
NUMBER HEALTH AND- ENTERED HER
HOUSE. INSURANCE OR HOW STOCK
IS PROTECTED IN MAINTAIN. AND
THAT ALL OF US ARE A TO SHELTER
PLACE AND HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY UP WITH
THE- OR UNHEALTHY CAN. THAT ARE.
PROBABLY REASONS WE ARE JUST A
PART OF TEMPLE YET MEANINGFUL
BELL THANK. GIVEN THEM ACIDIC
RIGHT TO ENFORCE THOSE AND THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED AN EXAMPLE OUT
OF LOS ANGELES BUT IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL WE FACE THE
SAME PROBLEMS- OFTEN
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS WITH
INCONSISTENT ENFORCEMENT AND
OTHER BARRIERS AND THEN ON TOP
OF THAT YOU HAVE POLICIES SUCH
AS THE ONE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS WHICH PREVENT
ENFORCEMENT WITH MODELS LIKE WE
DON'T EXPECT WE DON'T IN FACT
IF THERE'S AN AFFECTION CASE
PENDING OR WE DON'T ENFORCE
THAT THE RENTS HASN'T BEEN PAID
WE DON'T INSPECT SECTION EIGHT
UNITS. ALL OF THOSE DIRECTLY
FRUSTRATE THE PROTECTIONS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ENACTED TO
ENSURE THAT TENANTS CAN ACCESS
THOSE RIGHTS IN THE RESULT IS
TENANTS FORCED TO LIVE IN
DANGEROUS AND SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS WERE UNABLE TO GET
JUST A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO CALM AN INSPECTOR
WHO IS TASKED WITH PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC AND MAKE A BASIC
INSPECTION AND DOCUMENT THE
PROBLEM THAT THAT LEAVES THEM
VULNERABLE BOTH TO UNSAFE
CONDITIONS BUT ALSO. ADVECTION
INTIMIDATION AND RETALIATION IN
EXACTLY THE WAY THAT THEIR
FATHER WAS DESCRIBING SEVERAL
OF THOSE REASONS WE WOULD URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS VERY SIMPLE.
MEASURE THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES AND- SO THE TIME
WE'LL OPEN UP TO PUBLIC. LOOK
TO SEE IF ANYONE AND COMMITTEE
WERE WHICH IS TO SPEAK. SEE NON
GO TO THE REMOTE. ANALYSERS ARE
ONE OF THE REMOTE STATIONS
LET'S GO TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO. AB EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT BURKE
AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
YEAR MIKE IS UP. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE YOUR MY
KIDS UP BUT ALSO. LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IS HEALTHY HOUSING
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR BIKE IS UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ERIC PAYNE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF INSTITUTE WE SANDERS ON
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED NINETEEN YOUR MIKE IS
UP BUT- HELLO KELLY BEING WITH
HEALTH NET AND CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SERVING
ALMOST TWO MILLION MEDICAID
MEMBERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT CREATE
THANK YOU. BLIND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY OR MY KIDS UP I
APOLOGIZE BLIND ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN YEAR MIKE IS UP.
PROTECTED GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CLEAN GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- C. A. R. WILL OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT UNTIL
IT IS AMENDED TO CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE IN ITS PROVISIONS.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED NINETY NINE
YOUR MY KIDS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR TURN MEMBERS ON YOUR LAWLER
ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT IN SUPPORT.
AND ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO YEAR
MIKE IS UP. DAVID WHEATLEY AN
INDIVIDUAL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE LINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. CAPE TOWN
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS. MISTER CAR. THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THE SOMEONE THAT'S
REPRESENTED TENANTS IN LANDLORD
TENANT COURT- THERE'S NO DOUBT
AND PARTICULARLY IN SITUATIONS
WHERE TENANTS ARE BEING EVICTED
AND DIDN'T REALIZE- THAT THERE
ARE NUMEROUS- VIOLATIONS OF THE
EMPIRE ONCE OF HABITABILITY IN
THEIR UNITS AND THEY WOULD JUST
THEY WOULD RESPOND BY SAYING.
WE ARE BRING IT UP THERE NEVER
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THEIR NEVER
FIX IT YOU KNOW AND- THE EVENT
OF THE DAY THERE ARE THERE
BASICS THE IDEA SOMEHOW PEOPLE
WERE TO GO TO THEIR LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGE AS A DESK FOR
THEM THEY GO BECAUSE IT'S A
LAST RESORT BECAUSE THERE
ISSUES HAVEN'T DEALT WITH I GET
THOSE THAT ARE LANDLORDS. YOU
KNOW THAT YOU LOOK MY FAMILY
HAS BEEN DOZEN PROP RENTAL
HOMES SECTION EIGHT WE'VE NEVER
HAD ANY CONTRA THE LOCAL%
ENFORCERS BECAUSE WE KEEP
PROPERTY TO BREAK CONDITION
THIS ISSUE THE FIRST
IMMEDIATELY THE DALLAS THE KIND
OF WHY WOULD YOU WANT. THE NO
ONE'S GONNA BE FEEL THE NEED TO
GO REAL IS THAT THERE. THERE
ARE THERE ABOUT ACTORS AND I
GET THAT GOOD I SOMETIMES HAVE
TO HAVE A- BURDENS PLACE ON
THEMSELVES BUT OF THE BAD. BUT
REALITY THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
SOME HOME SOMEONE'S HOME. WE
HAVE HAVE STANDARDS PLACE. THAT
ALLOW THEM TO THE BILL. HEALTH
AND SAFETY IS. THAT THAT ARE
LOW GOVERNMENTS HAD RESPONSE TO
AND IN THE- SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
SHOW UP ON THEIR RENT THEY
SHOULD THE SHORT THING SAID
FIVE NOTE. TO THE REALITY IS
THAT SEPARATE FROM THE
STANDARDS BY BE UP AND SO. I
APPRECIATE- APPRECIATE THIS AND
WAS. BOTH LIKE THEM AT THIS
TIME. ALL OF THE REFORMS. FIVE
YEARS MARKETABILITY TO CALL
THAT GOES ON INSIDE HERE TO
READ- HIGH- OF- RIGHT WANTED TO
IN PARTICULAR- HOUSE ACTUALLY
GOT BURNED OUT OF THE GROUND.
THEY WOULD READ BRAND NEW FROM
THE GROUND UP AND WITHIN SIX
MONTHS OF THE FOR CONDITION
AGAIN NOT EVEN IF IT BECAME
AVAILABLE. RUBIO AND YEAH AND
THERE IS TALK. DAGAN SO I HAD A
FRONT ROW SEAT IN AREAS WHERE-
AND BASICALLY YOU HAVE
SLUMLORDS. AND THOSE ARE
DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS AND THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY IN THE CITY
THAT I'VE WORKED IN- THEY DID
GO HANDLE THOSE- BUT HE HE THE
MORE IT SEEMS WE SHIFT ALL THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON TO THE
LANDLORD- I THINK. THE MORE WE
SEE WE HAVE THE IRRESPONSIBLE
TENET SIDE OF THIS. SO YOU KNOW
YOU AT NIGHT I STRUGGLE WITH
THESE- BECAUSE I KNOW BOTH
SIDES AND- I JUST I JUST WISH
WE WOULD NOT CONTINUE TO PAINT
LANDLORDS IS THE BAD GUYS AND
ALL THESE BECAUSE I HAVE
BELIEVE ME THERE'S PLENTY OF
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY. AND
UNLESS THIS BILL WOULD WOULD
HELP DISCERN WHO IS ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CONDITION
OF THE PROPERTY AND HOLD THEM
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT NOT JUST
THE LANDLORD AND IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO SUPPORT IT SOME OF. MY
COMMENTS THANK. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR CONTINUED
WORK ON THIS ISSUE I THINK WE
ALL AGREE THAT EVERYONE
DESERVES A HOME THAT'S SAFE AND
FREE FROM HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
AND AS SOMEONE WHO HAS HARPER
LEGISLATION TO TACKLE THE PAIN
HAZARDS IN OUR STATES HOMES ARE
UNHAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND LOOK FORWARD TO. SEEING IT
MOVE THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND WITHOUT ANY FINAL
COMMENTS SURE- JUST A QUICK
RESPONSE MISTER SEA ARE TOO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT- AND
MAYBE YOU WERE REFERRING TO A
DIFFERENT BILL BECAUSE THIS
BILL DOESN'T PUT ANY NEW
WHATSOEVER THIS BILL ACTUALLY
PUTS A RESPONSIBILITY ON
MUNICIPALITIES TO DO
INSPECTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CURRENT RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT LANDLORDS ALL HAVE TO
PROVIDE A HABITABLE RESIDENTS
IS BEING DONE RATHER THAN
TELLING TENANTS I'M SORRY WE
WON'T ENFORCE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO AND INSPECT. BECAUSE WE
DON'T LIKE YOU THAT'S WHAT IF
YOU HAVE A SAFETY RECALL ON
YOUR CAR ALLOWING A CAR COMPANY
TO SAVE YOU WE DON'T HAVE TO
GIVE YOU A RECALL BECAUSE
YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT ARREARS ON
YOUR PAYMENT. YOU HAVE WE
SHOULD EXPECT OUR LANDLORDS TO
PROVIDE WHAT'S ALREADY UNDER
THE LAW OF THE HABITABILITY
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE THAT'S WE
DON'T CHANGE ANY OF THAT BURDEN
THEY CAN ALWAYS GO TO ATTEND IF
THEY THINK OF TIME AS DAMAGE
SOMETHING BUT IT'S
INCONCEIVABLE TO ME THAT WE
HAVE CITIES VERY FEW BUT WE
HAVE A FEW CITIES IN THE STATES
THAT ARE REFUSING TO DO CODE
ENFORCEMENT BUT REFUSING TO DO
INSPECTIONS. THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS A BILL BILLS ABOUT CHANGES
NOTHING FOR LANDLORDS
WHATSOEVER IT CHANGES A
RESPONSIBILITY OF
MUNICIPALITIES AND THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE HAD CHILDREN DIE
IN THE STATE AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHOW YOU THE ARTICLE BECAUSE
THE CITY REFUSED TO GO TO THOSE
SLUMLORDS AND HAVE THEM IN
FORCE AND SAID THEY TOLD THE
TENANTS BUT THEY WERE BEHIND ON
THE RENT AND SO IT WAS ALL UP
TO THEM TO LIVE A CERTAIN WAY
AND CHILDREN DIED BECAUSE OF
THAT. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE TO PROTECT.
OUR VULNERABLE TENANTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WITHOUT MODEM SO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION TO
PASS TO THE CAN APPROPRIATIONS
TROOPS OUR QUEUE I SAY ARE
DON'T KNOW YEAH NO GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA KILEY.
HIGHLY NO MAIENSCHEIN CORK
SILVA HI FOLKS SILVA I WEEKS
WEEKS I. FIVE YOU TO THERE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU. I
WANT TO CALL UP THE NEXT ITEMS.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. EIGHT
EIGHTY. S. AGUIAR-CURRY.
ANAHEIM MISTER BLASIER
INTELLIGENCE- I KNOW YOU'VE
NEVER BILLS TO PRESENT AND SHE
HAS ONCE APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING HER TO PRESENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING MASKS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
EIGHT EIGHTY LEGISLATION TO
SPEED AFFORDABLE HOME
RECONSTRUCTION IN THE WAKE OF A
DECLARED EMERGENCY.
CALIFORNIA'S RECENT NATURAL
DISASTERS HAVE DEVASTATED
COMMUNITIES AND THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVED THROUGH THE MANY OF WHO
WE ARE STILL REBUILDING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD HOMES AND LIVES. THE
WILDFIRES OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE STORY
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES IN
THE COUNTIES OF BUTTE. COLUSA
GLENN LAKE MENDOCINO NAPA SANTA
BARBARA SHASTA CINEMA TRINITY
IN VENTURA. THE DEADLY CAMPFIRE
ALONE DESTROYED THE ENTIRE TOWN
OF PARADISE NEARLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES KILLED EIGHTY
FIVE PEOPLE IT WAS THE
DEADLIEST FIRE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. FIVE OF THE SIX
BIGGEST FIRES IN TOTAL ACREAGE
OCCURRED IN TWENTY TWENTY WITH
THE LOSS OF TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED STRUCTURES AND MORE
THAN THIRTY LIVES. FEDERAL
DISASTER FUNDING TRADITIONALLY
THE MAJOR SOURCE OF FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR NATURAL DISASTERS
IS INSUFFICIENT AND TAKES YEARS
TO OBTAIN. IT TOOK NEARLY TWO
YEARS AFTER THE DISASTERS FOR
HUD TO SIGN OFF ON ANY OF THE
STATE'S PROPOSALS TO RESPOND TO
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES. AND HE WAS FOUR
YEARS BEFORE THE FUNDS WERE
DEPLOYED AS A RESULT RECOVERY
HAS BEEN SLOW AND THOSE MOST IN
NEED NEED OF HELP DO NOT GET IT
TO LONG AFTER THE DISASTER. AB
EIGHT EIGHTY WHAT ESTABLISH THE
AFFORDABLE DISASTER HOUSING
REVOLVING DEVELOPMENT AND
ACQUISITION PROGRAM. THE FUNDED
OF PRE DEVELOPMENT EXPENSES-
ACQUISITION CONSTRUCTION
RECONSTRUCTION AND
REHABILITATION PROPERTY TO
DEVELOPER PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE STATE'S.
FEDERALLY DECLARED DISASTER
AREAS THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED
DAMAGE AND LOSS OF HOMES
OCCUPIED BY FIVE OR AFFECTING
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO APPLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR
FUNDING TO MAKE SHORT TERM
LOANS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ANDCONSUMERS. THE FUNDS COULD
BE USED FOR A VARIETY OF
HOUSING RELATED POST DISASTER
RECOVERY EFFORTS INCLUDING
ACQUISITION REHABILITATION AND
NEW CONSTRUCTION. THE SHORT
TERM LOANS WOULD BE REPAID
THROUGH THE FEDERAL DISASTER
RECOVERY FUNDING IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE PRE BUT THE APPROVED
PLAN OF ACTION. WITH ME TODAY
VIRTUALLY TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY OUR SHAUNA OF
SHAUGHNESSY WITH THE PRESIDENCY
OF THE COMMUNITY HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES CROP COOPER OXEA
CORPORATION. IN MARION
MCFADDEN. OF FROM ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT'S GOOD
HERE WITNESSES PALOOZA BILL. IF
WE GO TO THE OPERATOR TO A-
SEAN O'SHAUGHNESSY OR MARY
MCFADDEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED THE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SEAN O'SHAUGHNESSY AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF COMMUNITY
HOUSING IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ARE BEING CUTE
SHASTA CAME OUT GLENN COLUSA
BETTER IN YUBA COUNTY IN OTHER
WORDS MANY OF THE COUNTIES THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES MOST
NOTABLY THE CAMPFIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. OUR REGION
HAS BEEN ON THE EDGE OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS FOR MANY YEARS
THE WILDFIRES HAVE ELIMINATED
FIRST. IF YOU COUNTY WE STILL
HAVE OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLD IN ACTIVE DISASTER
CASE MANAGEMENT. AND NEARLY ONE
THOUSAND ON THE WAITLIST NINETY
SEVEN HOUSEHOLDS ARE STILL ON
SCENE AT THE STATE HOUSING. OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION IS
EXPLODING. THE BIGGEST BARRIER
TO RECOVERY IS OUR LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHTY COULD HELP PREVENT
OTHER COMMUNITIES FROM
EXPERIENCING THE SAME DEGREE OF
LONG TERM DISPLACEMENT AND
DISRUPTION. IT'S SUCH A LONG
FUND HAD EXISTED MY
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY HOUSING
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM COULD IT
STARTED THE RECONSTRUCTION OF
OUR MULTI FAMILY PROJECT
PARADISE COMMUNITY VILLAGE. A
YEAR SOONER WHILE WE ARE ON
TRACK TO FINISH THIS AUGUST
IMAGINE THE IMPACT IF WE COULD
HAVE FINISHED SOONER. NONE OF
THE OTHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT IN PARADISE HAVE
STARTED REBUILDING AT MOST
DIDN'T STRUGGLING TO FIND
FUNDING AND WE DON'T EXPECT TO
SEE CDBG DR DOLLARS. UNTIL THE
END OF THIS YEAR OR EARLY NEXT.
THIS COULD HELPED ME HOME IN
INCOME. START ON PATH TO
RECONSTRUCTION. NOW THREE YEARS
LATER IF THEY SPEND THEIR
INSURANCE MONEY ON RENT OR
OTHER ESSENTIALS. CDBG DR WON'T
COVER THAT GAP THE BAND STARTED
REBUILDING RIGHT AWAY WHICH
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY WOULD ALLOW
THIS WILL NOT EVEN BE AN ISSUE.
IT IS MY DEEP DESIRE THAT NO
OTHER DEVELOPER HAVE TO
STRUGGLE LIKE WE DID TO REBUILD
PARETEUM IN THE VILLAGE. AND
THAT THAT DISASTER IMPACTED
INDIVIDUALS DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
YEARS FOR THE RESTORATION OF
THEIR HOME THEIR LIVES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AB EIGHT
EIGHTY IS THE FIRST STEP IN
MAKING A QUICKER RECOVERY
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. FIRMAS
MCFAYDEN PLEASE. AFTERNOON
AMEREN EXPANDABLE AND APPRISE
COMMITTEE PARTNERS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT EIGHTY
CENTER PROJECT WORK BECAUSE
AFTER IMPACT IN COMMUNITIES
FROM CALIFORNIA PORTER RICO I
PREVIOUSLY ADMINISTERED HOW
DISASTER RECOVERY PROGRAM FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LEARNED THE
SPEED OF FEDERAL DISASTER
PROGRAMS IS PAINFULLY SLOW EVEN
WHEN CONGRESS ACTS QUICKLY T
APPROPRIATE MONEY- ON AVERAGE
IT TAKES JURISDICTIONS MORE
THAN EIGHTEEN MONTHS AFTER
DISASTER TO STAND UP THERE
HOUSING RECOVERY PROGRAMS. AND
IN LARGE PART THAT'S BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENT AS YOU
HEARD AFTER THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FIRES THAT TOOK HARD
TWO YEARS AFTER CONGRESSMAN THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO SET RULES
FOR THE RECOVERY PROGRAM AND
APPROVED CALIFORNIA'S PLAN AND
IN THE MEANTIME HOUSING
REBUILDING STALLED. ST NEW
EXACTLY HOW MUCH FEDERAL GRANT
FUNDING WAS COMING BUT COULDN'T
SUPPORT REBUILDING CALIFORNIA
CAN'T MAKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MOVE MORE QUICKLY
BUT YOU HAVE THE POWER TO START
REBUILDING IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
WOULD CONSIDERABLY SHORTEN THE
TIME BETWEEN DISASTER AND
RECOVERY BY ENABLING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO MAKE SHORT TERM
LOANS ON GOOD TERMS AND
CONDITIONS. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CONSUMERS. FIND
WILL BE USED TO WITH. AND
BRIDGE THAT TIME AND TELL TEAM
UNDER OTHER GRANTS CAN BE USED
TO PAY THE LOAN OFF. THE REPAID
FUNDS WILL THEN BE REVOLVED
INTO NEW BRAKES ON. TWENTY
TWENTY BROKE ALL RECORDS FOR
WILDFIRE DAMAGE WITH MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES
DESTROYED OR DAMAGED. THE STATE
AND LIKELY TO SEE MUCH MORE
DAMAGE TO THE INCREASING IMPACT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE SO I
RECOMMEND PASSAGE OF EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN INNOVATIVE AND
ARREST WAY TO SHORTEN THE TIME
BETWEEN DISASTER RECOVERY FOR
IMPACTED CALIFORNIANS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEE ANY THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION WITNESS TO THIS
BILL SO LET US NOW GO TO.
NUMBER THE PUBLIC THE WISHES
BECOME PUBLIC COMMENTS HERE IN
THE CHAMBER R. FOR SPEAKER.
MARCH DIVERSE THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LET'S NOT
GO TO REMOTE STATIONS. UNLESS
THERE'S ANYONE PROMOTE STATION
LET'S GO TO THE OPERATOR. OPEN
IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
SUPPORTERS OR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT EIGHTY AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS BURKE EIGHTY B. EIGHT
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO AND LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP.
ONE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. AND ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOUR MIKE IS
UP. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOUR MAKE IT
UP. DAVID WHEATLEY AN
INDIVIDUAL IN SUPPORT. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED NINETY NINE YOUR MY
KIDS UP. AND ONE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THROUGH
MUCH OF LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS. MR
GAVE BIRTH YEAH I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE AUTHOR ON A
REALLY THOUGHTFUL AND IMPORTANT
MEASURE I AM PLEASED TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY AS AS WE
MENTIONED BEFORE I THINK IT'S A
REALLY. IMPORTANT APPROACH I
THINK IT'S VERY TIMELY I WAS
RECALLING- YOU KNOW AT A TEXT
MESSAGE EXTENDED YOU AND I HAVE
SOME MONTHS AGO. WHEN ONE OF
THESE WILDFIRES WAS WAS GOING
THROUGH MY COMMUNITY- WE TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT A FORTUNE
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK IS
GONNA UNITE FOLKS OF CERTAIN
ELECTED OFFICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SPECTATORS THAT
ONE FIND ANOTHER ALL OF US
WOULD BE TOUCHED. BY THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS AWHILE
PARTS I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE I THINK YOU COME UP WITH
A REALLY TOP ON INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS. JUST WANTED TO
APPLAUD YOU FOR IT AND I'LL BE
PROUD TO SUPPORT IT TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL TAKE THAT
AS A MOTION REFORMIST APRIL.
THERE'S A SECOND. ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. I'M SURE YOU DO MOVE
IT OR- OKAY VICE YOU'RE MOVED
IT SO BY MR GAVE. THIS ONE IS
THE AUTHOR APPRECIATE. YOU
OFFERING SO TO GET MONEY TO
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS MORE QUICKLY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT TODAY I DO UNDERSTAND.
THERE IS AN ACCOMPANYING BUDGET
ASSET THIS IS DEPENDENT ON IT
WISH YOU LUCK IN MOVING THROUGH
THAT PROCESS LET ME ASK IF YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS. OTHER
THAN- COLLEAGUES I KNOW WE'RE
ALL ON A TIME FRAME BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY IS THAT. WHEN YOU
GO TO MY COMMUNITIES AND YOU
SEE HOUSE HARD THIS STRUGGLE TO
GET BACK IN THEIR HOMES IT HAS
BEEN TOUGH AND THIS IS WHAT I
THINK A VERY. THOUGHTFUL WAY TO
DO SO IN GETTING BACK IN AND
WE'LL HAVE THIS REVOLVING FUND
SO AGAIN. I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTIONS THE PATH TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TRUE HI. TWO I
SAY ARE TOO HIGH. HI GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. FINALLY I MAIENSCHEIN
CORK SILVA. BOOK SILVA. FIVE
WEEKS WEEKS BY. WE HAVE SEVEN
TWO ZERO SIR. HER BILLS PASSED
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK. HAVE A GOOD
WEEKEND. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS FROM OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA MISTER BLOOM- FILE
ITEMS TWO THREE FOUR AND FIVE.
MISTER BLOOM WHAT'S YOUR
PLEASURE. IT PROBABLY MAKES
SENSE FOR ME TO START WITH-
FILE ORDER THREE GO THROUGH A
THREE FOUR AND FIVE AND THEN
COME BACK TO SOUNDS GOOD FILE
IN THREE AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
BLOWN. THANK YOU TO THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WILL START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THAT. AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL
INVALIDATE DENSITY RESTRICTIONS
AND PRIVATE PROVIDENCE THAT
CONFLICT WITH LOCAL ZONING. AND
MAKE THEM UNAFFORDABLE AGAINST
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
pSOMEONE ON THE LINE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GIVE YOURSELF.
THANK YOU ESTABA PRIVATE
COVENANTS OR AGREEMENTS
ATTACHED TO A PROPERTY AND
REMAIN UNENFORCEABLE EXCUSE ME
REMAIN ENFORCEABLE EVEN AFTER
THE PROPERTY IS SOLD. UNTIL THE
MID TWENTIETH CENTURY RACIALLY
RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS WERE USED
AS A TOOL TO SEGREGATE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND BAR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. COURT
DECISIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAVE MADE THESE
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
ENFORCEABLE FORTUNATELY HOWEVER
THESE COVENANTS OFTEN CONTAIN
OTHER VESTIGES OF
DISCRIMINATION SUCH AS LIMITS
ON THE NUMBER AND SIZES OF
UNITS THAT CAN BUILD THAT CAN
BE BUILT. THESE DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS ALSO CONFLICT WITH
LOCAL ZONING CODES THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT YET DESPITE THEIR
DISCRIMINATORY ORIGIN AND CLEAR
CONFLICT WITH CURRENT LOCAL
ZONING. THESE RESTRICTIONS
REMAIN ENFORCEABLE AGAINST IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
THREATS OF LAWSUITS OVER THESE
COVENANTS MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
TO GET TITLE INSURANCE COVERAGE
AND FUNDING FROM LENDERS THE
TIME AND EXPENSE NEEDED TO
REMOVE THE COVENANTS DETER
DEVELOPERS FROM ACQUIRING AND
DEVELOPING ON THESE OTHERWISE.
IDEAL PROJECT SITES AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL ENSURE THAT
THESE PRIVATE COVENANTS CANNOT
BE USED TO CURTAIL MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS MEASURE
CLARIFIES THAT DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS IN PRIVATE
COVENANTS ARE UNENFORCEABLE
AGAINST A 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL HELP BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS WHILE
PRESERVING AND STRENGTHENING
LOCAL CONTROL. LASTLY THERE
BEEN SOME CONCERNS OVER THE
MODIFICATION DOCUMENT
PROCEDURES LAID OUT IN THE BILL
AND I APPRECIATE RECEIVING
FEEDBACK REGARDING THE LANGUAGE
FROM THE LAND TITLE ASSOCIATION
AND THE COUNTY RECORDER'S I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE MORE
CLARITY ON THOSE ISSUES.
CALLING IN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ARE BRANDON PAY AT WITH
PUBLIC COUNCIL AND TERRIBLE
ROSTERS WITH THE COMMUNITY
CORPORATION OF SANTA MONICA
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITHOUT TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW. EITHER OF THE
WITNESSES TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
BOTH BUT DEADLINES ARE OPEN. MS
BROSQUE THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS MY NAME IS HARPER
OUT AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNITY CORPORATE SANTA
MONICA WHERE MIDSIZE NONPROFIT
THAT IS OPERATED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE AFFLUENT WEBSITE
L. A. COUNTY FOR ALMOST FORTY
YEARS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD
BLOOM FOR CHAMPIONING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OFFERING
TO SELL WE'RE HERE TODAY THE CO
SPONSORED EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE BECAUSE OF THE PORTABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WE BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHARE WITH
POLICYMAKERS THE OBSTACLES WE
FACE. IN HOPES THEY CAN BEAT
THAT THE ISSUES RAISED BY
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY ADDRESS HISTORICAL
SEGREGATION IN NEIGHBORHOODS AS
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
I THINK RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
WITH EXTREMELY DISTURBING
PROVISIONS ALONG WITH
ACCOMPANYING DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS THE MULTIPLE CAR
USUALLY HAVE CHOSEN TO WALK
AWAY FROM THIS PROJECT BUT
AFTER THE EVENTS OF THE PAST
YEAR I FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CHALLENGE THE STATUS QUO AND
TAKE AWAY THE POWER THAT THE
SEGREGATIONIST COVENANTS THAT
HAD. THREE MOPEDS COVENANT WILL
COST A LOT OF MONEY IN AN
EXTENDED QUARTER PROFIT AND FOR
PROPERTIES ALREADY UNDER
DESIGNATED MULTI FAMILY BY THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT IN ONE PROJECT WE'RE
WORKING ON THE PROPERTY IS
DESIGNATED MULTI FAMILY BY THE
CITY AND THE ONLY THING
STANDING IN THE WAY IT IS
PRIVATE OUTDATED COVENANT AMONG
DONORS FROM THE NINETEEN
FORTIES. IT WOULD PROVIDE OVER
A HUNDRED UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN AN AFFLUENT
COMMUNITY THAT HAS CURRENTLY NO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OTHER
PROJECTS HAVE FACED SIMILAR
ISSUES WE KEEP WE APPRECIATE
OUR CO SPONSOR PUBLIC COUNCIL
WHO WILL EXPLAIN MORE ABOUT THE
COVENANT WE CANNOT BEGIN TO
ADDRESS EXCLUSIONARY
NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT A
DRAFTING RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS A STEP TOWARD ENDING.
DESEGREGATION OF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE PUB COUNCIL
WITNESS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS FIND RENDON
PAT I'M THE STAFF OF WITH
PUBLIC COUNT THE NATION'S LARGE
PROBLEM LOS AND MY WORK FOCUSES
AND ON A HOW IN THE TO NOW TO
FIRST THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CARE
ATTENTION TO THE HOUSING
PRACTICE HEARING. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE IS DESIGNED TO
CONTINUE THE FIGHT TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS AND HELP REMEDY THE
HISTORICAL HARMS THAT
DISCRIMINATORY HOUSING POLICIES
A PAT ON LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
OF COVERAGE HAVE ON MANY. MANY
PEOPLE ARE. WITH THE HISTORY OF
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
THAT WERE DESIGNED TO PROHIBIT
PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM LIVING AN
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGACY OF
THOSE RESTRICTIONS. THOSE
RACIST RESTRICTIONS LET'S NOT
AND- RECORDED RESTRICTIONS THAT
LIMIT DEVELOPMENT ON A GIVEN
PARCEL TO A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL NITS OR TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF BUILDINGS.
ARE OFTEN TREATED AS
ENFORCEABLE TODAY EVEN IF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS ARE MORE LIMITING
THAN THE APPLICABLES OWN CODE.
AND USE RULES. AND EVEN IF
THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE
CONTAINED IN THE SAME EXACT
DOCUMENT. AS EXPLICITLY RACIST
RESTRICTIONS ON WHO MAY LIVE
THAT. EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
TO MAKE THE PRIVATE DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS IN RECORDED
COVENANTS UNENFORCEABLE AGAINST
A 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. THEREBY REMOVING A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED THEM.
EMPLOYER IMPORTANTLY THE BILL
WOULD NOT MAKE NOTE WOULD
REQUIRE ANY CHANGES LOCAL
ZONING CODES ONE NINETEEN S.
RULES. IT WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW A
PROPERTY OWNER TO BUILD AS MUCH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON A GIVEN
PROPERTY AS THE APPLICABLES OWN
CODE WOULD ALLOW. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL DOES NOT DO WAY WITH
RESTRICTIVE COVENANT ENTIRELY.
ANY RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF
PROPERTY NOT RELATED TO THE
SIZE LOCATION OR NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL IMPROVEMENTS. WOULD
REMAIN FULLY ENFORCEABLE. AND
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
EXPLICITLY ALLOWS THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY TO RETAIN ITS
CHARACTER BY ENFORCING DESIGN
AND ATHLETIC RESTRICTION. OR BY
IMPOSING MAIN IF YOU TO KEEP.
COMMON AREAS IN THAT REPAIR. I
WE HAVE A PUBLIC COUNCIL BEFORE
HOUSING LEADERS. REQUEST YOUR
VOTE. A SEVEN TO ONE TO
CONTINUE PROCESS OF RECKLESS
THE WHOLE. THE PALACE HAVE OF
RACE SICK OF. AND
DISCRIMINATORY HOUSING POLICIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO
NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT SO WE'LL
START WITH PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN THIS COMMITTEE WERE STARTING
ON THE MICROPHONE. YOU KNOW I
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OUR STANDARDS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LET'S NOT GO TO THE
REMOTE STATIONS. IS THERE
ANYONE PROMOTE STATIONS. IF NOT
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES TO
INDIVIDUALS AND WISH TO SPEAK
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO AB SEVEN TWENTY
ONE. BLOOM RELATED TO COVENANTS
AND RESTRICTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE COMMENT. FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO MY
PANELIZED TWO HUNDRED TWENTY.
TWO TO THE OPERATOR MY
APOLOGIES I JUST MISS THAT
THERE IS ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION INFORM OPPOSITION-
ANTHONY HOLDEN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION LIKE TO ASK MR
HELTON IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS I
I'M HERE ANTHONY HELPED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. WHAT WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL
DUE TO CONCERNS. WITH A PLAQUE
OF- RECORDING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE RESTRICTIVE COVENANT
MODIFICATION FORMS WE ARE
ENGAGED WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND ARE PURSUING
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD RESOLVE
THOSE CONCERNS. WE APPRECIATE
THE OTHERS COMMITMENT TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS ISSUE. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING OUT A
SOLUTION- THAT WILL MAKE THIS
BILL A LOT OF MORE EFFECTIVE
TOOL AND NEED A MOMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK THANK
YOU ARE BACK TO THE OPERATOR
AGAIN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY YEAR MIKE IS UP.
THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WE WERE IN OPPOSE
POSITION BUT APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE DOING NOW THANK
YOU. LINE NINETY YEAR MIKE IS
UP AND. ALEX WHAT WITH WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE COURT. LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE YOUR MIKE
IS UP. NICCOLO DELUCA BEHIND
AND WE HAVE A NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU. BLIND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ERIC PAYNE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN
INSTITUTE- SPEAKING UP AND OUT
TO PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN YEAR MIKE IS UP.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
FLIGHT ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
YEAR MIKE IS UP. JACKSON LOOP
WITH THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
TWO ONE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO WE ARE MY
KIDS UP. DAVID WHEATLEY AN
INDIVIDUAL IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE YEAR MIKE IS UP.
JOB OF THE GATE WITH ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. LINE TWO
HUNDRED ONE YOUR MIKE IS UP.
ROBBIE JONES FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE SANTA MONICA
BLACK LIVES THE AGENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SIX YOUR MY KIDS UP. A SHOT SHE
HAD AND THEN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR COMMUNITY TRANSIT LOS
ANGELES THAT BROAD BASED
TRANSIT HAS BEEN JUST COALITION
IN LOS ANGELES. AND JUNK THE
PART. LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN YOUR MY KIDS UP. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRS IS MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AS OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER AS A BILL WOULD THREATEN
THE- CURRENT AND FUTURE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS. WE DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE AUTHORS
TIRELESS WORK TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ALL OF THAT
TIME AND ATTENTION THE
SPONSORING THE AUTHOR STAFF
HAVE GIVEN US- AND YOU LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS AND
FINE RESOLUTION BEFORE THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE YOUR MIKE
IS UP. SH SH. LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINETY NINE YOUR MICROSCOPE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BURKE ON AWHILE OR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR ALL
HOUSING AND THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT IMPORT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT- MY KIDS UP.
ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER WOULD
BE INCLINED TO CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT CALLING
IN SUPPORT. AND LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR YOUR MIKE
IS UP. ONE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK OU LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE IS ANY
DISCUSSION. OUR MOTION WITH THE
BILL FOR THE MOTION IS A MOTION
FOR MISTER KILEY. JUST
UNDERSTAND THAT IND OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THIS
ARISES SO- IF I OWNED A LARGE
ATTRACTIVE PROPERTY AND THEN
ONE TO SELL OFF PART OF IT- BUT
WANTED TO YOU KNOW ENTER INTO
AN AGREEMENT WITH A BUYER AT TO
RESTRICT THE LEVEL OF
DEVELOPMENT. ON THAT PARCEL IS
YOUR BILL STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING OR ALLOW THE OWNER TO
THEN GO BACK IN IN A RACE THAT
RESTRICTION NOTICE UP LIES ONLY
21100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS. THE PRESUMABLY IF
THAT PARCEL WERE USED FOR THAT
PURPOSE THAN THE INITIAL
AGREEMENT WOULDN'T HOLD OR IS.
THAT NOT THE SORT OF SITUATION
THAT IS LIKELY TO COME UP. SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE LANGUAGE
IN THE DEED IS A VESTIGE OF
THIS- ORIGINALS- RESTRICTIVE
COVENANT LANGUAGE- IT WOULD NOT
BE EFFECTIVE BUT- PERHAPS WE
SHOULD ASK- MS BROSQUE US. TO
FURTHER ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
RIGHT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I
DON'T THINK- ACT I THINK IF
THERE WAS A RESTRICTIVE
COVENANT BANK WASRECORDED THAT
WOULD NOT ALLOW- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE THE
DENSITY RESTRICTIONS THIS WAY-
A FAX FAX BUT I THINK- THE
LIKELIHOOD AS I MEAN I THINK
THERE IS A QUESTION REGARDING
CREATING A NEW COVENANT OR AN
EXISTING. RIGHT CREATING A NEW
COMPANY. I MEAN IT WOULDN'T
MATTER TO INTO THE LAND OF THE
BILL IT'S EXISTING OR NEW.
THANK YEAH WHAT COUNCIL CAN
HELP AND STRUGGLING IT'S ACTING
ON HOW TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
HI YEAH THIS IS BRANDON PAYER
CAN PUBLIC PUBLIC AND THEN
THANKS FOR THE IMPORTANT
QUESTION- SO THE WAY THAT- WE
WOULD ENVISION THAT SCENARIO
THAT YOU DESCRIBED IS- YOU'RE
STILL FULLY ABLE TO CONTRACT
INDIVIDUALLY WITH- THE PERSON
THAT YOU'RE SELLING A PROPERTY
TO- AND THAT AGREEMENT BETWEEN
YOU AND THAT THAT. BUYER WOULD
BE ENFORCEABLE- BUT EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE WOULD MAKE A
CHANGE WHERE- IF- SOME YEARS
FROM NOW- ANOTHER BUYER WHERE
WE'RE PURCHASING THE PROPERTY-
THAT THAT WOULD. NECESSARILY BE
INCOMPATIBLE AGAIN- OKAY THAT'S
WHAT I AM I WAS KIND OF GETTING
OUT SO IT DOESN'T THEN RUN WITH
THE LAND SO TO SPEAK- AND- YOUR
ABILITY IS THE SELLER TO SORT
OF- LIMIT. ACTIVITY ON THE
ADJACENT OR SOMEWHERE WHEREVER
THAT PARCEL MAY BE A KIND OF
STOPS WITH THE- THE IMMEDIATE
FIRE IS THAT RIGHT. RIGHT AND
THAT IS THE I MEAN YOU COULD
AGAIN YOU'D BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE NEW WITH THE
NEW BUYER OF COURSE AND AGAIN
THIS IS ONLY APPLICABLE TO A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
AGAIN ONLY APPLICABLES IN A
SCENARIO WHERE THE PROPERTY IS
ALREADY ZONED FOR WHATEVER
PARTICULAR DEVELOPMENT WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAPPENING ON THAT
PROPERTY- BUT YES THAT THE
AGREEMENT WOULD HAVE TO BE
PERSONAL. AND- IT WOULD BE
IDEAS JUST GIVING THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- CONTROL OVER
OVER LONG TERM DEVELOPMENT
DECISION. RATHER THAN
DEVELOPERS FROM TRUMP. YEAH
PERHAPS DECADES THERE ARE EVEN
MORE. RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS
FORWARD I THINK WE'RE ALL AWARE
THAT- RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY IN OUR
STATE OR COUNTRY WITHIN
EXCLUSIONARY IMPACT. MOST
NOTABLY- IMPACTING THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT- THEY
HAVE ALSO HAD OTHER IMPACTS AS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE ANALYSIS
WITH REGARDS TO THIS BILL. I
THINK THIS BILL DOES ADDRESS AN
IMPORTANT BARRIER TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION BY.
ESTABLISHING THIS PROCESS TO
REMOVE THESE RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS. DO APPRECIATE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA TITLE SITUATION
AND OTHERS HAVE RECEIVED HAVE
RISKS OF RAISING CONCERNS WITH
A BILL. THAT I UNDERSTAND YOU
WILL BE. WORKING TO POTENTIALLY
ADDRESS IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
YEAH WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
WILL. SUPPORT THE BILL AS
AMENDED TO DATE. AND THERE WAS
A MOTION AND A SECOND LET ME
ASK THE AUTHOR IF YOU ANY FINAL
COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU WITHOUT
MADAM SECRETARY. OCEAN IS PASS
A AMENDED THIS TYPE CAN-
COMMITTEE ON TRADITION. FEW ARE
FEW FIVE THEY ARE CO. YEAH
VOTING APRIL. ALL WELL AYE
KILEY. AND THE MAIN SHOW CORK
SILVA HI FOLKS SILVA I WE- AND
TO THREE ZERO SAN WE WILL HOLD
THAT FOR OPEN HOLLISTER FALLON
FOR AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU- EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO IS
A DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD
SUNSET MORE RESTRICTIVE LAND
USE REGULATIONS CONTAINED IN
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT PLANS AND
HELP BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AS SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES FOR RDAS
WERE DISSOLVED IN TWENTY
TWELVE. AND SUCCESSOR AGENCIES
WERE CREATED TO WIND DOWN THEIR
ACTIVITIES DUE TO ITS ENORMOUS
SIZE AND SCOPE THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES DID NOT ELECT TO BECOME
THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO THEIR
FORMER RDA INSTEAD GOVERNOR
BROWN APPOINTED A DESIGNATED
LOCAL AUTHORITY TO TAKE ON THE
DUTIES OF THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY.
DESPITE THE DISSOLUTION LAND
USE REGULATIONS UNDER RT A
REMAND EFFECT IN THE CITY.
RTA'S MORE STRINGENT LAND USE
POLICIES HAVE CONFLICTED WITH
PROGRAMS CREATED UNDER VOTER
APPROVED MEASURE JJJ NAMELY THE
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES
PROGRAMMER TOC. THE
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT PLANS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCENTIVES
HAVE SLOWED THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO
WILL SIMPLY PROVIDE CLARITY BY
SUNSETTING THE MORE RESTRICTIVE
LAND USE REGULATIONS IN THE
FORMER RDA. THE BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT THE CITY CONTINUES
TO MEET ITS OBLIGATIONS UNDER
MEASURE JJJ. AND PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCENTIVES
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF LA'S
REDEVELOPMENT TO SOLUTION
REQUIRES LEGISLATION TO REMOVE
UNNECESSARY HURDLES AND BOOST
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT CLOSER TO
TRANSIT AND AMENITIES. AND ON
MY OFFICE RECEIVED CONCERNS
WITHIN THE LAST- A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME THE BILL WOULD
WIPE AWAY TENANT PROTECTIONS
AND HISTORIC DISTRICT
PRESERVATION AND I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THAT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL SO I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING OUT THE
LANGUAGE IN AMENDING THE BILL.
TO PROVIDE FURTHER CLARITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WE HAVE CRAIG BULLOCK THE
PLANNING DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF COUNCILMEMBER MITCH
O'FARRELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO THE OPERATOR TO CURRENT
HELLO MISTER BOTH TO SPEAK.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
CRAIG PORT AND THE PLANNING
DIRECTOR FOR COUNCILMEMBER
MITCH O'FARRELL PROFITS. PRIOR
TO JOINING HEALTH NUMBER OF
PERILS OFFICE I WORKED FOR FIVE
YEARS THAT THE TRA LA AT
DESIGNATED LOCAL AUTHORITY AND
THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO THE
FORMER COMMUNITY REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND BEFORE THAT I
WORKED EIGHT YEARS FOR THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY. SO
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES BORDERS
OFF NEARLY A DECADE AGO WE
CONTINUED TO BE HAMPERED BY
THEIR ALLOCATED REQUIREMENTS.
THAT TEND TO INCLUDE ALL THE
TICKET TODAY AN FIR LIMITATIONS
THAN WHAT IS ALLOWED BY. THE
COMMUNITY PLANS AND BUILDING. I
THINK YOU OF THE CITY'S. ORANGE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM A BILL
APPROVED PORTABLE HOUSING AND
FOR. WHICH INCLUDES QUITE THAN.
THAN THOSE OF BONUS LEGISLATION.
WHICH CLAIMS AGAINST THIS BILL
IN LARGE PART ARE BEING MADE BY
INDIVIDUALS AND PARTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH PLAINTIFFS THAT
HAVE A HISTORY OF FILING
LITIGATION AGAINST THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY. THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCY AND THE CITY.
AND ALLOW THREE TO FOUR YEARS
APPLICATION HAS INVOLVED
THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF HOUSING.
INCLUDING HUNDREDS OF UNITS THE
PORTABLE HOUSING WITH AN INFILL
DEVELOPMENTS SHE IT'S BEEN-ARGUED THAT EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
TWO WILL REDUCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT OBLIGATIONS
THAT THE CITY. HOWEVER IN
RELATION TO INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL
ONLY CLARIFIES BUT IT'S ALREADY
BEEN DETERMINED AND REAFFIRMED
BY THE COURTS. WHICH IS THAT
THESE OBLIGATIONS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY IN THE FACT THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN IN EFFECT SINCE THE
STATE DEVELOPED REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES. IN ADDITION THE
TENANT PROTECTIONS THAT ERE
FOUND IN THE REDEVELOPMENT
PLANS WERE ONLY APPLICABLE TO
PROJECTS. THAT RECEIVE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY WHICH IS
NOT. OCCURRED TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. THIS IS THE TIME TO
THIS. IS REDEVELOPMENT PLANS
WORK. TO REMOVE AND A PART
HOUSING HAVE BEEN WEAPONIZED
AGAINST THOSE OBJECTIVES. THIS
BILL WOULD RESULT THAT. I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL AND
THEY DO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO AT
THIS POINT WE WILL OPEN IT UP
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. MISSY IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SEE NON ARE GOING TO THE
REMOTE STATIONS. SEE NON LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ASK ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO SPEAK. EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT THIRTY TO BLOOM RELATED
TO. THE CITY OF LA AND THE
TRANSFER OF FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY LAND USE
PLANS AND FUNCTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
A. B. THIRTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AN ONLINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT YOUR MY
KIDS UP. ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR MIKE AT THE. WHY IN
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION- WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AMENDED CONSISTENT
WITH THE LETTER WE SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE AND WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO-
WORK ON AMENDMENTS ON THE
ISSUES THAT WE RAISED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE YOUR MY KIDS
UP. THANK YOU YESTERDAY HUNTER
LOS ANGELES TENANTS UNION
HOLLYWOOD LOCAL CASE WORKER ARE
TERRIFIED AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE YOUR MY
KIDS UP. JENNIFER HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT AND I WE DON'T I
THINK THE AMENDMENTS TO DISPEL
THAT. KEEP INTACT THE 15%
AFFORDABILITY FOR THE
REDEVELOPMENT AREA AND- NOT TO
ABSOLVE THE CITY OF SECTION
THIRTY THREE FOUR ONE THREE
WHICH WAS NOT IN THE ORIGINAL
DISSOLUTION OF THE CRA FROM THE
LEGISLATURE BUT HAS BEEN.
INTERESTINGLY PUT IN HERE- TO
ABSOLVE THE CITY OF ITS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THEIR REDEVELOPMENT AREA SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR- TO MAKE AMENDMENTS
AND- HOPE THAT WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PRESERVE
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS- FOR THE. CITY OF
LOS ANGELES THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THANK YOU DAVID
WHEATLEY AN INDIVIDUAL IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED. LINE
NINETY THREE YOUR MY KIDS UP.
YES THIS IS FRAN OFFENHAUSER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HOLLYWOOD
HERITAGE IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED. LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE OR MY COULD OPEN.
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
YOUR MY KIDS OPENS PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS ARTURO CASTRO WITH
HOUSING IN IN RIGHT- AND AGAIN
AT THE UPSET WE WILL SUPPORT
ONLY AMEND THAT THIS NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT MORE CLOSELY- AND
AVOID THE ANY AND PROTECTIONS
BE STRIPPED AWAY AGAIN. LET'S
WORK ON AMENDING THIS WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. IN A LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINE YEAR MIKE IS UP
AND. TODD MARTIN AN INDIVIDUAL
STRONGLY OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
COMMONS. IS OUR MOTION OF THIS
BEFORE THEIR SECOND. THEIR
SECOND VOTE OKAY. I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR- AND- YOUR VISION A
GOAL FOR THIS BILL WHICH IS TO
ENSURE BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND- WE ALL KNOW THAT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES HAS LED TO A LOT OF
ISSUES AT. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE HOW TO RECONCILE I KNOW
THAT WHEN I OPEN UP MY EMAIL
BOX THIS MORNING I THINK I WAS
SURPRISED I KNOW THE AUTHOR WAS
SURPRISED ON SOME OF- THE LAST
MINUTE EMAIL WE GOT INVOLVING
SOME POTENTIAL OPPOSITION
ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS- COMMITMENT TO WHILE
WORKING THROUGH THESE AYE NOW.
I THINK HE'S PROBABLY ONE OF
THE LAST PEOPLE THE LEGISLATURE
THAT WOULD WANT TO SEE ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON TENANTS SO-
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO KEEP WORKING ON
THAT BUT WITH THAT ARE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD LET ME ASK THE AUTHOR
IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
THANK YOU AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH
THAT- THIS IS A MOTION TO PASS
TO ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL LOCAL
ASSEMBLY KAMALA GOVERNMENT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TWO FIVE TWO FIVE THEY
ARE DOPE HI SHARED BY GABRIEL.
CHOLERA WELL RIGHT I. KILEY
KILEY I. MAIENSCHEIN COOK SILVA
THANKS TWO BYE WEEKS. FOUR FIVE
ZERO ZERO ZERO YOUR BILL PASSES
AND A WITHOUT LET US GO NOW TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE THANK YOU
AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT.
CURRENTLY IF A JURISDICTION
DOES NOT ADOPTED HOUSING
ELEMENT BY THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE IT MUST ADOPT A
REVISED HOUSING ELEMENT EVERY
FOUR YEARS RATHER THAN EVERY
EIGHT. THIS PENALTY FOR NON
COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING ELEMENT
ADOPTION DEADLINES HAS PROVEN
INEFFECTIVE AND LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. FOR
EXAMPLE UNDER CURRENT LAW A
CITY OR COUNTY CAN ADOPT A
LEGALLY DEFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENT ALMOST FOUR MONTHS
AFTER THE STATUTORY DEADLINE
WITH NO CONSEQUENCES. IN FACT
SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED
FAULTY DRAFT ELEMENTS BY THE
DEADLINE KNOWING THAT
ADDITIONAL CHANGES AND
REVISIONS WERE NECESSARY TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW. JUST TO
AVOID A PENALTY OF HAVING TO
REVISE THE ELEMENT IN FOUR
YEARS. IN SOME JURISDICTIONS
THE ADOPTED ELEMENT WAS NOT
REVISED TO CORRECT THE LEGAL
DEFICIENCIES FOR MORE THAN
TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
DEADLINE AND IN SOME CASES NOT
FOR YEARS. FOR INSTANCE ONE
CITY ADOPTED A DRAFT ELEMENT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT HAD FOUND
DID NOT MEET STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. THE CITY TOOK NO
FURTHER ACTION TO REMEDY THE
LEGAL DEFICIENCIES UNTIL TWENTY
NINETEEN FIVE YEARS AFTER THE
CITY WAS ORIGINALLY SUPPOSED TO
ADOPT ITS ELEMENT. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT WOULD ADDRESS
THESE PROBLEMS BY CLARIFYING
THE LAW TO REQUIRE ADOPTION OF
AN H. C. D. APPROVED HOUSING
ELEMENT BY THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE. THE BILL ELIMINATES
THE FOR YOUR PENALTY AND
INSTEAD PROVIDES THAT FAILURE
TO ADOPT ON TIME OBLIGATES THE
JURISDICTION TO COMPLETE ANY
NECESSARY RESOUNDS WITHIN ONE
YEAR. RATHER THAN IN THREE
YEARS A LOT FOR JURISDICTIONS
THAT ADOPT ON TIME. THANK YOU
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I
WITNESSED TODAY IS BRIAN
AUGUSTA CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO YOUR
WITNESS MISTER ACOSTA. THANK
YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS BRIAN GOT
STAFF IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT- ADDS THAT. THE
AUTHOR NOTED THAT THE ORIGINAL
THOUGHT BEHIND THIS- PENALTY
WHICH WAS WELL INTENTIONED AND
SUPPORTED BY HOUSING OUT TO GET
THAT THE AT THE TIME. AND
THOUGHT THAT THE PENALTY OF
HAVING TO ADOPT TO HOUSING
ELEMENT IN A YEAR PERIOD WOULD
ENGENDER GREATER COMPLIANCE BUT
IT REALLY HASN'T ACHIEVED THAT
GOAL FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
HE'S DESCRIBED AND WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF. INSTANCES IN WHICH CITY
THE DOCTOR HOUSING ELEMENT
SIMPLY TO MEET. THE TIME LINE
AS THAT IS NOWHERE NEAR-
COMPLYING WITH STATE LAW SO THE
CHANGES MADE BY THIS BILL WILL
PAY CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE BY
ENSURING THAT THE IN THE
HOUSING ELEMENT. DR ED AND
APPROVED BY EACH CD DURING. THE
REQUIRED TIME LINE. AND THEN.
CHANGE THE CONSEQUENCE TO BE
ONE THAT'S MORE MEANINGFUL
REQUIRE THAT CITIES ADOPT- THE
THAT HAVE MEANT MISSED THE- TO
THE RESULTING WITHIN HERE THAT
BECOMES PARTICULARLY CRITICAL
FOR THOSE CITIES AS WE'VE SEEN.
WHO HAVING MISSED THE DEADLINE
LINGER FOR YEARS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ONCE THEY DO GET
THAT OUT AND ALL THE. PLAYERS
THAT WE GET THE SITES WE NEED-
APPROVED QUICKLY. SO FOR THOSE
THREE- WE THINK THIS IMPORTANT
OF THE LAW. WELL HELP IN THIS
UPCOMING. GETS MORE HOW THEY
CAN BE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
TONIGHT ABOUT. AND WITH THAT
THERE ARE NO OTHER WITNESSES-
THAT WILL BE TESTIFYING HIS
MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. LET US NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT LET ME SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND- THE COMMITTEE ROOM
THERE ARE NONE ANY IN THE
REMOTE STATIONS. THERE ARE NONE
GOING TO THE PHONE LINES TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT.
BLOOM TO PLEASE DO SO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS BURKE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
I'M NOT LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
TWO YOUR MIKE IS UP. DAVID
WHEATLEY AN INDIVIDUAL STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AND LINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO MIKE IS UP. SLIDE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN CASH. YES I'M ON
THE WRONG BILL I WANTED AB ONE
ONE FIVE I WILL WAIT THANK YOU
SEE. AND THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
I DO WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
AS AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET US
BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS. THERE'S
A MOTION WITH THE BILL. SECOND
ARM. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
THIS IS A BILL THAT CONTAINS
TWO THEMES. ARE THE REPORT IN
THE HOUSING DISCUSSION TODAY
ONE HOW INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR STATES TO FOLLOW STATE
HOUSING LAW. AND THEN SECONDLY
HOW DO WE LEVERAGE EIGHT CITIES
NAY OF PROFILES AND PLICIES.
AND OF THIS BILL IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO BILL
FROM LAST YEAR WHICH- MANY OF
US SUPPORTED AND WITH THAT
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AGAIN. OUR THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION TO MOVE THIS FORWARD IN
A SECOND ANY FINAL COMMENTS BY
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY. MOTION TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO TRY TO HI SAY
ARCHR NOW. NO GABRIELLE. KALRA
RIGHT FULLER AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN COOK SILVA KIRK
SILVA I WEEKS. ONE THREE ZERO
SIR ALL RIGHT WILL HOLD THE
BILL OPEN AND- I THINK YOU HAVE
ONE FINAL BILL I DO THINK THE
FILE ITEM TO AB ONE FIFTEEN
MISTER BUSH THANK YOU UC I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT- MY FINAL BILL THE-
AFTERNOON AB ONE ONE FIVE A
BILL TO BUILD HOUSING NEAR
TRANSIT CENTERS AND JOBS DURING
A TIME WHERE THE STATE
DESPERATELY NEEDS MORE HOUSING.
I'D LIKE TO STOP AND START BY
ACCEPTING THE- COMMITTEES
REQUESTED LANGUAGE WHICH READS
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT HI ROAD LABOR
POLICIES TO USE A SKILLED
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE FOR
PROJECTS UTILIZING THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS ACT. AB ONE
ONE FIVE WILL PERMIT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITH AT LEAST 20%
OF UNITS FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TO BE ALLOWED ON
ANY SITE DESIGNATED FOR
COMMERCIAL USES. COMMERCIAL
CORRIDORS ARE IDEAL AREAS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BECAUSE
THEY'RE CLOSE TO AMENITIES
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND JOB CENTERS.
HOWEVER MODERN ZONING THAT
SEPARATES RESIDENTIAL AREAS
FROM COMMERCIAL AREAS RESTRICT
THE NUMBER OF SITES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. HOUSING PROJECTS
ARE THAN DELAYED OR EVEN HALTED
DURING THE ARDUOUS AND COSTLY
PROCESS OF A ZONE CHANGE THIS
PROCESS SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITS
THE POTENTIAL FOR MORE SITES TO
ALLEVIATE THE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
AB ONE ONE FIVE WILL INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF AVAILABLE SITES
FOR HOUSING WHILE MAINTAINING
THE CHARACTER OF THE COMMUNITY
HOUSING PROJECTS WILL BE
LIMITED TO INFILL SITES AND
SPECIFIED DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS
REQUIRE THAT THE HEIGHT AND
DENSITY OF THE BUILDINGS OF THE
PROJECTS. NEAR THE SURROUNDING
RESIDENTIAL AREAS. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL EXEMPTS SITES ADJACENT
AREAS DESIGNATED FOR INDUSTRIAL
USE TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF RESIDENTS. AND LASTLY
AB ONE ONE FIVE WILL EXEMPT
CITIES THAT ZONE FOR THEIR
SIXTH RING THE CYCLE. I AM
COMMITTING TODAY TO EXEMPT
AREAS THAT ARE PROTECTED BY
LOCAL VOTER INITIATIVES AND
AREAS DESIGNATED TO BE VERY
HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES THESE
ARE AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROMISED
LONG AGO- WE WILL TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. AS THAT'S THE MOST
LOGICAL PLACE- TO DO THAT BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
ARE LISTENING AND UNDERSTAND
THAT WE WILL BE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS MARINO
WYANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
THE POINT I'M GOING OUT TO
EUROPE WITNESS MS WANT. TWENTY
HOUSING CONSORTIUM WERE PLEASED
TO SPONSOR AB ONE OF FIFTEEN
WHICH IS THE REINTRODUCTION OF
AB ONE THIRTY ONE OF SEVEN FROM
LAST YEAR WHICH PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY THIRTY FIFTY TWO TO
FOURTEEN. THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF UNITS
AVAILABLE TO LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS AND ALLOW THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CRITICALLY
NEEDED HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL
CORRIDORS NEAR TRANSIT AND JOB
CENTERS. THE DEVELOPMENT OF
MAKES USE THE MIXING SOME
PROJECTS ON UNDER UTILIZED
RETAIL AND OFFICE PROPERTY CAN
SERVE AS A CATALYST FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING HOUSING
SHORTAGE. A DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY STUDY BY THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
INNOVATION FOUND THE
CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREAS HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF LAND
ZONED FOR COMMERCIAL USES. AND
THE ROUGHLY 41% OF COMMERCIAL
ZONES IN THE STATE'S FIFTY
LARGEST CITIES CURRENTLY
PROHIBIT RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT AS DETERMINED BY
THEIR BASE ZONING DESIGNATIONS
AND ALLOWING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE AREAS
COULD INTRODUCE NEW HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES IN VIRTUALLY
EVERY. NEIGHBORHOOD. WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO I TO DEVELOPING
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
WOULD HELP BUILD DESPERATELY
NEEDED HOUSING FOR STRUGGLING
FAMILIES SENIORS LOW WAGE
WORKERS A FARMWORKERS AND
VETERANS WHILE ALSO EXPANDING
AND PROVIDING HIGHER WAGES FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE THAT
WILL BUILD THESE HOMES AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE JUST
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE OF THE MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESS AND- ON THE
LINE SHOULD BE RON MILLER THE
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY. OF FROM
THE L. A. AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL MR MILLER. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M RON MILLER
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE LA
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING TRADES.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF FORTY
LOCAL UNIONS A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND SKILLED AND TRAINED
MEN AND WOMEN TODAY. THIS WEEK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE
FIVE. THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS STATEWIDE. TO BUILD
MOSTLY MARKET RATE HOUSING
WHERE HOUSING IS CURRENTLY NOT
ALLOWED. IT IS A VERY BIG BILL
THAT WILL REMOVE LOCAL DECISION
MAKING ACROSS THE STATE. IT IS
DESIGNED TO REMOVE LOCAL
CONTROL AND ZONING DECISIONS.
THIS BILL REMOVED LOCAL VOICES
FROM A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAPPENING ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND SPECIFICALLY IT REMOVES THE
VOICE OF HALF A MILLION OF OUR
MEMBERS STATEWIDE. IN A
CONVERSATION THAT WILL AFFECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES THEIR SCHOOLS
IN THEIR LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IT DOES THIS WITHOUT TAKING
IN INTO CONSIDERATION THE
WORKFORCE THAT WILL BUILD
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING. THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES PRESIDENT
ROBBIE HUNTER HAS SAID YOU
CAN'T SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
POVERTY AND HOUSING BY DRIVING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES INTO POVERTY. WE'VE
BEEN WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
WORK WITH THE SOFT AUTHORS
SINCE LAST SESSION TO ADD
LANGUAGE THAT WE PROTECT
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS INTO THIS
BILL. INCLUDING LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THE PAYMENT OF
FAIR WAGES. WHAT I HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL WHO WILL BE WHO
HAVE BEEN UNWILLING TO SUPPORT.
A TRAINED WORKFORCE AND
INSTEAD. WOULD RATHER SUPPORT
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY WHERE
WAGE THEFT AND LABOR VIOLATIONS
RUN RAMPANT. DEVELOPERS WILL
MAKE MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS
OF THIS LEGISLATION PASSES.
THERE IS NO RELUCTANCE TO ALLOW
THIS PROFIT TO OCCUR THERE'S NO
EFFORT TO ASK LAWYERS
ACCOUNTANTS LOBBYIST TO MAKE
LESS MONEY. THERE IS ONLY IN
THE EXPECTATION THAT
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS MAKE LESS
THAN THEIR TRAINING SUPPORTS.
THE INTENT LANGUAGE THIS
COMMITTEE IS OFFERED IS JUST
THAT INTENT LANGUAGE. ALTHOUGH
WE THE GESTURE THIS DOES NOT
PROTECT WORKERS THE LEGAL
MECHANISM TO PROTECT THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE HAS BEEN
SENT TO THIS COMMITTEE AND WE
ASK THAT THIS LANGUAGE BE
AMENDED AND AB ONE ONE FIVE.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR DOES NOTHING MORE THAN
BRING CONSTRUCTION WORKERS OUT
OF THE SHADOWS OF THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY PROVIDE
THEM WITH A PATHWAY TO
APPRENTICESHIP AND A GOOD
MIDDLE CLASS CAREER IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. AND
EVERYONE GETS TO CONTRIBUTE TO
BUILDING THE WORKFORCE OF
TOMORROW. WE CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION UNTIL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE PAID
FAIRLY AND A SKILLED WORKFORCE
IS SUPPORTED. THIS IS A BIG
BILL SO IN ADDITION TO THESE
BASIC LABOR STANDARDS THAT MORE
THAN A DOZEN LEGISLATORS. HAVE
ADDED TO THEIR BILLS THIS
SESSION WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SEE A SUNSET ON THE BILL OF
THIS SIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THIS WHEN WE GO
TO PAY COMMENTS MONEY FOR START
WITH NUMBER. IN THE AUDIENCE
HERE. AND THIS GUY HEARING.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN LEHANE ON
BEHALF OF THE HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WHO REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. WE APPRECIATE THE
ASPIRATIONAL LANGUAGE IT WOULD
LIKE ACTUAL LANGUAGE TO PROTECT
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. MARCH DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PUT A
PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S NOT
GO TO THE REMOTE STATIONS. SEE
NON LET'S NOW GO TO THE
OPERATOR TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT OR AB
ONE ONE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
N. T. ROWE THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE. NINE ZERO. JANET LINE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE YOUR BIKE
IS UP. TAKE ME FAN ON BEHALF OF
BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE NINETY FOUR YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. ONE NINETY FOUR YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. EDITOR'S OFFICE
YOUR LITTLE ONE ZERO FIVE IN
THE BILLIARD OPPOSITION. LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWO YOUR MIKE IT UP.
SHE HELPED TO BUILD BRITAIN
CROSSED WHICH WITH STAY
BUILDING IN STRONG OFF. TO THE
STABILITY LABOR. LINE ONE HI
EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS UP. HI THIS
IS MARK THOMAS OF INTERNET
UNION OF ELEVATOR LOW EIGHT
STAND THE STATE BUILDING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ONE ONE FIVE.
LINE ONE HI SIX YOUR MIKE UP.
STOP YOU WHAT THE PROMISED
FORCE SEVEN WITH THE STATE BILL
TRADES IN OPPOSITE. AB. ONE
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YOUR BIKE AT THE. JOHN COURTS
SO YOU A LOW THIRD EIGHT
FRANCISCO AND BUT WITH THE
BUILDING AND I. THANK YOU. LINE
HUNDRED YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHAIRMAN
THE STILL FOR OUR IN BEHALF
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YEAR MIKE IS
UP. GOOD AFTERNOON TONY YOURS
WITH THE NORTHERN CAL CARP
LOCAL THIRD OUT ALAMEDA.
STANDING WITH THE BILL THE
TRADE IS STRONG OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE WAY CAR. WHY ONE FIVE
YOUR MIKE IT OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ARGUE FOR OUR A LOCAL
THIRTY FARMERS IN STEAM UP. ONE
ONE. BLIND TO HUNDRED FOR SIX.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX FOR MY COULD OPEN. MR
YOUR REMEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION- IN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED AS DESCRIBED IN
OUR LETTER AND- AS DESCRIBED IN
OUR OFFICE THANK YOU. BLIND TWO
HUNDRED FOR EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. ONE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP.
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR MIKE IT'S UP. DANFORTH
AGENTS PERPETRATORS YOU A FOR
THREE COVERING THE NINE
STETHOSCOPE AREA COUNTIES STAND.
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. ONE THIRTEEN.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX YOUR
MY KIDS UP. ROBERT SMITH LOCAL
DIRECTOR MAKERS TRAY THIS
COUNCIL SO. WE STAND UPON TO
BILL ONE ONE FIVE IN IT REVIEW
THAT THE BILL SO THE
UNDERGROUND AND DOES NOT
PROTECT WORKERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MUCH I DON'T WANT RELY.
MEMBERS OF IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANISER AND
WHAT YOU SEE OR THE THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER. I KNOW WHAT
HUNDRED FIVE YOUR MIKE THE
LOCAL HI THIS IS MANDY PRIMEROS
EMAIL MONO SECTORS KIND BILLING
TRAITS AND- TO A ONE ONE FIVE
WHICH BUILDING. WHY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE YOUR MIKE HELP. HI
YEAH MICHAEL WOULD TEAMSTER
WELL FOUR THIRTY ONE AND
FRIENDS CAME THIRD JOINING THE
STATE TRAY IN THEIR OPPOSITE TO
EIGHT. I WANTED. LINE ONE HI.
MIKE IT UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ROB
STILL KERN ON BEHALF OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR
WE PROUDLY STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE FIVE.
LINE NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THIS IS DAVID ANSEN
WITH YOU A LOCAL THREE NINETY
EIGHT REPRESENTING MY THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
VOTE- STAND IN OPPOSITION TO
THE ONE ONE FIVE. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO YOU'RE MY
COULD HELP. HI THIS IS DAVID
WHEATLEY I STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE UNION PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. LINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARK UP FROM
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTROPHORETOGRAM FIVE
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA SAN
JOAQUIN CALAVERAS COUNTY WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
ONE FIVE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN YEAR MAKE IT
UP IN. I'M REQUIRED TO GET YOU
A LOCAL TO FIFTIES DEEPER
REFRIGERATION SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS STRONG LOS
ANGELES WHICH DOWNSTATE
BUILDING TRADE CONSTRUCTION AND
OPPOSING AB ONE ONE FIVE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR
MIKE IS UP. HI MY NAME IS BOB
ALONG WITH JUST A COUPLE
SIXTEEN AND WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE FIVE
THANK YOU. AND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. CHRIS GRIBBLE LOCAL UNION
SIX SIX NINE ZERO THREE
QUARTERS. OF REPRESENTING
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PLUS MEMBERS
WE OPPOSE BILL AB. ONE FIFTEEN.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY OR
MAKE IT UP. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ONE RESULTS TO
DISCUSS PAINTERS NOT LIKE
TRADES AND WE TRAVEL TO STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE FIFTEEN. WHY TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE YOUR MAKE IT
UP. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ROBBIE COBLE'S WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES
REPRESENTING OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND- PIPING PROFESSIONALS
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
ONE ONE FIVE. AND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR MIKE IS UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT IN
THE DOLLARS THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES AND WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE FIFTEEN.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. ONE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON THIS IS JEFF ROBERTS
WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
LOCAL UNION TO NINETY FOUR
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION. AB. ONE
ONE FIVE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN YEAR MIKE IS A- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WORKING
ALL THE PRESIDENT WESTERN
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF ROOFERS
WATER PREFERS AN ALLIED WORKERS
AND WE'RE JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU. AND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE YOUR MY KIDS UP. ONE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE YOUR MY
KIDS UP. FIND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHNNY
GENERO THE PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES DISCOUNT OF THIRTY SIX
AND I'LL BE AFTER TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERSHIP HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FRED WOMEN BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR YOU A LOCAL
THREE FORTY THREE ABOUT THE
PLUMBERS AND STEAM FITTERS NAPA
AND SOLANO COUNTIES JOIN IN THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. ONE ONE FIVE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE YOUR MY
KIDS UP. LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE
NINETY FIVE YOUR MY KIDS UP.
SHANE BOSTON DOES MANAGER OF
LOCAL FOR IT FOR PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS INTERCOUNTY WE
STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES ON AB
ONE ONE FIVE. THANK YOU. LINE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOU'RE
MY KID UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN SPALDING
REPRESENTING THE KERN INYO AND
MONO COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE ARE JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU SHE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
YEAR MIKE IS A. LINE TWO
HUNDRED YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. I
LINE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS READY TO
RESPOND YOU KNOW PRESIDENTIAL
LOCAL PARK- GOING IN THE TOPS I
AP ONE ONE FIVE THANK YOU. WHY
TO HER FIFTY YOU'RE MY IS UP.
DOUGLAS WITH LATE LOCAL TWENTY
FOUR WE WITH THE SAY BUILDING
TRADES OPPOSITE OF AB ONE ONE
FIVE THANK YOU. WHY NINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT YOUR MY
KIDS UP. FIND ONE I LIKE WHAT.
HELLO MY NAME IS RANDALL NEED
NOT WITH THIS RECOUNT IN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION. LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR MY KIDS UP. I
APOLOGIZE LINE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO YOUR MARKET UP. LINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY I COULD OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TODD MARTIN WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS IN THE ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTOR JOURNAL
CORRESPONDENT WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE ONE FIVE
BECAUSE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
THANK YOU. WINE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR YOU MIGHT GIVE UP.
WHY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
YOUR MY KIDS UP. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD NOT BUT. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE. HELLO
THIS IS YOUR NEW YORK WITH
LABOUR'S INTERNATIONAL UNION
PACIFIC SOUTHWESTREGIONAL
OFFICE REPRESENTING OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND LABORERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE ONE FIVE
THANK YOU. ONE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY YOU MIGHT GET UP. LINE
TWO HUNDRED OVER A MEMBERS THIS
IS MITCHELL BATTLE WITH THE AND
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN INCH FONG
OPPOSITION WITH. ITS. AND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD NOT. OR OKAY. ONE ONE
COULD UP- GILBERT CRITICAL.
LOCAL PARK THIRTY ONE TEACHERS
FRESNO. AND I SUPPORT AB ONE
ONE FIVE. WELL. WHY LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE YOUR MIKE IS
A- THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
BACKING ACROSS THE- CRANK ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME CALLING ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IN THE LINE. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE FIND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR YOU MIGHT GET A. THANK GOD
REDDING. MEDICARE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES. MISTER
KALRA. I THINK IT WAS THIS YEAR
AND- THANK YOU- WITH THE SAME
NUMBER FOR BRING THIS FORWARD
AND I JUST YOU KNOW I. A COUPLE
THINGS I HAD I HAD A BILL LAST
YEAR ALSO THAT WAS WITH-
REGARDING- PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
FINES WHATEVER THE WEATHER WAS
FOR. WATER POLLUTION TRANSPLANT
OR A LIBRARY OR- OR EVEN A
SUBSIDY- FOR A MARKET RATE
HOUSING AND IT REQUIRED
PREVAILING WAGE- AN- PARTY
ARGUMENT WAS MADE AT TIMES.
FROM THE- BUILDING INDUSTRIES
LIKE WALTER GONNA MAKE IT HARD
TO BUILD IF YOU PUT THAT IN
THERE. AND I AND I DO AGREE
WITH UNDERLYING PRINCIPLE THAT
WELL. WE SHOULDN'T HAVE FOLKS
BUILDING THAT ARE GOING TO NEED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE SOME. OF BASIC-
STANDARDS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE GOOD WAGES AND-
THEREFORE AND GOOD QUALITY-
WORK AS WELL INTO THE PROJECTS
THAT WERE FUNDING. AND I DO
APPRECIATE- THE- INTENT
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PUT IN I
THINK THAT'S VERY HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF- A PATH FORWARD. I
THINK THAT IT DEFINITELY
DEMONSTRATES THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR OF. YOU KNOW
WHAT I WHAT I HOPE WILL BE UP
OF SOME- COMPROMISED THAT.
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION. OF
THE BUILDING TRADES AND YOU'LL
HAVE. TO THE IN TERMS OF.
THERE'S GOING TO BE- A
FACILITATION- FOR MORE BUILDING
OF HOUSING WHICH WE ALL NEED. I
MEAN I'M IT SOUNDS A-
DEFINITELY NEEDED AND YEAH I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY. ON
THESE SITES- HOUSING- THAT I
THINK. BE PUT OUT IN BE HELPFUL
IN AND CITIES WE WILL BE THEIR
GOALS REGION'S. IMAGE THEIR
GOAL. AND SO I GUESS MY ONLY MY
QUESTIONS WERE FIRST WITH YOU
FOR. THE- THE OVER EXCEPT IN
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT INTO
LANGUAGE. TO DEVELOP PAN HAROLD
PAUL USES GO TO SUCH WORK FOR.
PROJECTS YOU KNOW VERGE IS THAT.
OF AS YOU MOVE FORWARD IN A-
OTHER AND BE UP. OR OF THESE
FROM YOUR END TO TRY TO WORK
WITH TRY AND OTHER TO. GET A
LANGUAGE INTO THE THAT MAY. BE
MORE FOR IN TERMS OF THE OF
CALL JOBS. AT THOSE AFTER ARE
ON. AND TAKE PLACE WILL
CONTINUE- AND I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- IT'S NOT JUST
ME- THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN AT THE
TABLE AND HAVE BEEN. ACTIVELY.
ATTEMPTING TO NEGOTIATE. I DID
NOT APPRECIATE THAT AND I HOPE.
TO THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
DEVELOPERS AND OTHERS IT HELPS
A FORM HOUSING THAT- THEY'RE
BOTH. IN GOALS YOU KNOW BOTH
THE BILL OF THE FOR HOUSING.
AND- THE QUALITY OF THE JOBS.
THAT ARE BEING CREATED THROUGH
THAT HOUSING SO THIS IS THE
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE- I'LL-
BE VOTING HI WITH THE-
AMENDMENT. OF THE ACCEPTANCE OF
THE AMENDMENTS IN TERMS THE
INTENT LANGUAGE BUT I DO AGREE
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE IN
THERE. AND I'M HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE. CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT WITH THE FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLAR PERSON BUT THE
BUILDING TRADES I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE UP TO THAT WORK THINK
BACK ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU YOU
BUY JUST FOR CLARITY'S SAKE-
YOU MENTIONED THAT PREVAILING
WAGE. AND I WANT EVERYONE TO
KNOW THE PREVAILING WHICH IS
ALREADY PART OF THE- OF THE
NEXT. THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE HERE
THESE ARE IN. THE- IN THE- I'D
NOT IN THE I THINK IT'S A
EXCEPT THE- PART OF FOR- I'VE
MADE MS WHITE- CLARIFY THAT-
PREVAILING WAGE IS ALREADY PART
OF EVERY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT. YEAH OFFER BOTH ADD
PREVAILING WAGE AND ADD SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE LANGUAGE
SO LONG AS THEIR GUARD RAILS TO
ENSURE THAT IF A WORK FORCE
DOES NOT IS NOT THERE IN THEIR
BIDS ARE COMING IN THAT MEET
THAT REQUIREMENT THE PROJECT
COULD STILL MOVE FORWARD- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVE THIS TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL BUT I
WOULD BE. I WOULD BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT WHAT THE GUARDRAILS ARE
BECAUSE- DETAIL TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S OF. MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY- FOR THE AND I'M
SPEAKING FROM. REALLY FROM MY
LOCALITY FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I'VE SEEN.
DEVELOPMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT- BUT WITH HORRENDOUS WORK
STANDARDS AND SOUNDS A THAT-
THAT THAT DID HAPPEN BIG
SUBSIDIES OF ALASKA. IN RECENT
YEARS- IT WAS PART OF WHAT.
URGE ME TO- TO PUT FOR DENTAL
RIGHT THE LEGISLATION LAST YEAR
BUT THE BUILDING TRADES STOP
THAT WAS REMARKABLY- EITHER
SUBSIDIES MARKET RATE HOUSING
OR OTHER TYPES OF PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS- BUT I MEAN I KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS AND WE DON'T- HAVE
THE GUARDRAILS IN PLACE WITH
THE WORKERS- WHICH IS WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT. I'M GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR AS A BILL WAS FOR
THANK YOU UNDERSTOOD. THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS AS WORKS. I
THINK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR THAT
WANNA LINE- COMMENTS ALSO WITH
MIKE- FROM SAN JOSE- KNOW JUST
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED MORE HOUSING WE HAVE TO DO
THAT- BUT JUST AND CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AND A COMMITMENT
FROM YOU ON THAT WOULD BE AS
YOU HAVE GIVEN VERY HELPFUL SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT- UNDER THE PROPENSITY
WILL CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION. OF COURSE FROM
THE BEGINNING I'VE FELT THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- NOT
ONLY NEEDS TO BE COMPROMISED
BUT- I BELIEVE IT WILL BE. MISS
CLARK SILVA. I TO I'M GOING TO
SAY YES- UNDER THE SAME
CONDITIONS THAT YOU CONTINUE
YOUR EFFORTS REGARDING THE
OPPOSITION- I DO WANT TO MAKE
SOME MORE GENERAL COMMENTS
THOUGH RELATED TO HOUSING HE
SOME OF US HAVE NOW BEEN ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR A FEW YEARS
BUT SOME OF US HAVE WORKED IN
THIS SPACE I COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WE HAVE SEEN
MANY MANY BILLS COME THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE LAST
HANDFUL OF YEARS- THAT REALLY
ARE FOCUSED ON TRYING TO CREATE
REALLY A PACKAGE THAT MOVES
CALIFORNIA FORWARD AND WE KNOW
THAT TOO MANY WAYS AND TIMES
WE'VE FALLEN SHORT SO WHETHER
IT'S A GROWING HOMELESS.
POPULATION WHETHER IT'S TRYING
TO LOOK AT HOW DO WE HOUSE-
PEOPLE OF OUR COMMUNITY WITH
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
WHETHER IT BE LOOKING AT SOME
OF THE VERY VERY DIFFICULT
BILLS THAT HAVE COME TO OUR
COMMITTEE MIGHT COME AGAIN IN
THE FUTURE- WHAT IT BE RENT
CONTROL WE HAVE. DEALT WITH
VERY COMPLEX ISSUES AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE SO FOR. THOSE
THAT ARE OUT THERE LISTENING
WHETHER IT'S THE TRADES THE
BUILDING TRADES. WHETHER IT'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES
WHETHER IT'S- PEOPLE WHO DON'T
WANT ANY CHANGE AT ALL AND WE
HERE AT ALL WE HEAR PLEASE
DON'T SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S
TOO AGGRESSIVE ARE PLEASE MOVE
THIS FORWARD BUT WHAT WE KNOW
IS WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
ENTIRE ASPECTS HERE AND
HOUSING. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
FOR SURE IS WE'RE NOT BUILDING
ENOUGH AND AS WE DON'T BUILD
ENOUGH WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PRODUCTION WE CERTAINLY SEE
THOSE PRICES INCREASE FOR EVEN
THE MOST- BASIC SINGLE FAMILY
HOME STARTER HOMES SOMETIMES
NOW AT LEAST AN ORANGE COUNTY
CLOSE TO EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH KEEPS MANY MANY
PEOPLE OUT OF THE MARKET. BUT
WE HAVE A LOT TO DO I SUPPORT
THIS BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
STARTING TO LOOK AT PRODUCTION
IT'S ABOUT STARTING TO LOOK AT
HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD- BUT I
WOULD JUST AGAIN SAY EVERYBODY
HAS TO TAKE SOME STEPS HERE AND
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE AT THE
TABLE WILLING TO US GET OUT OF
EACH OTHER'S WAY IN MANY WAYS-
SO. WILL KEEP LOOKING AT IT BUT
I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK
YOU I KNOW MR KILEY WISHES TO
SPEAK. JUST A CLARIFICATION I
HEARD FROM THE WITNESS THAT-
THERE'S GOING TO BE-
REQUIREMENT IS THE LANGUAGE
THAT PUTS IN SCUTTLED TRANS
WORK FIRST LANGUAGE AND
PREVAILING WAGE LANGUAGE BUT
THEN. THAT WOULDN'T APPLY IF
THERE AREN'T ANY DID SO UNDER
THOSE TREES THAT THAT PLAN FOR
HOW THIS IS GONNA OF ALL. I
DON'T WANT TO GET TOO FAR INTO
THE DETAILS OF NEGOTIATIONS
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT A VERY
SENSITIVE POINT RIGHT NOW- I'M
NOT SURE IF MS WHITE WANTS TO.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
THANKS- YES I WAS JUST- SHARING
WHAT WE HAD OFFERED TO THE
TRADES BACK IN JANUARY AS A
COMPROMISE- ADD TO IT TO
REQUIRE PREVAILING WAGE ANTI
REQUIRES SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE- WITH GUARDRAILS TO
ENSURE THAT IF BIDS DO NOT COME
IN TO MEET THOSE REQUIREMENTS
WE COULD STILL MOVE FORWARD
WITH OTHER KIDS. SHE SAID I WAS
OFFERED A AND IT WAS REJECTED
OR WHAT WAS THAT HI I WOULD SAY
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
ONGOING. I'M GOING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS MR
GRUBER. YES THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER I WOULD JUST ALONG WITH
THE GENERAL SENTIMENT THAT- MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES HAVE
EXPRESSED SO FAR AND JUST MAYBE
I DON'T OBSERVATION WHICH IS
THAT YOU KNOW I WISH YOU GREAT
SUCCESS IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS I
THINK THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE. WHERE WE CAN
DO TWO THINGS AT ONCE THAT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED FOR THE
STATE WE CAN CREATE SOME GOOD
PAYING JOBS THEY'RE GONNA PUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO WORK AS WE ARE
<c.green>OMING OUT OF A OF A ECONOMIC</c>
CRISIS TO COPE IN ALSO ADDRESS
OUR STATE'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS SO THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR A TRUE WIN
WIN FOR WORKERS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THEIR COMMUNITY SO
WE CAN DO A LOT HERE WITH. IF
WE CAN REACH SOME COMPROMISE SO
I WANT TO WISH YOU GOOD LUCK
WITH THOSE NEGOTIATIONS AND- I
WILL BE SUPPORTED- TODAY AS
WELL. THANK YOU. NO COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES. ALL OF. JOINED A-
THE SUN. THAT YOU'VE HEARD I.
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. WE
NEED TO HAVE. AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND HOW WE BETTER
UTILIZE UNDER UTILIZED
COMMERCIAL LAND FOR HOUSING.
ESPECIALLY FOR PORTABLE
HOUSING. ALSO AFFECT THE
BUILDING TRADES FOR THEIR-
STEADFAST SUPPORT. FOR ENSURING
THAT SUCH HOUSING IS BUILT. BY
WELL TRAINED WELL PAID
WORKFORCE. BOTH THE HOUSING AND
THE QUALITY OF JOBS THAT CREATE
THE HOUSING. ARE CRUCIALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK THAT'S A
VALUE THAT WE- ALL SHARE AND-
ON SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
SO WE CAN KEEP THIS.
CONVERSATION GOING. AS I
MENTIONED- TO AT LEAST A ONE OR
TWO OF YOU I'D ASK THE AUTHOR.
TO ACCEPT THE MEMBER LANGUAGE
THAT WE HAD TAKEN FROM SB FIVE
WHICH IS. THE HOUSING BOND
PROPOSAL BY SENATE. PRO TEM
TONI ATKINS. TO STATE THE
COMMITMENT OF OUR LEGISLATURE
TO A SKILLED. CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE I APPRECIATE. ARE THE
AUTHORS ACCEPTANCE OF THAT
LANGUAGE. AS I'VE DISCUSSED
WITH THE REAR STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE AUTHOR- WE KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS GOING TO. HAVE TO
BE SATISFACTORILY RESOLVED AS
IT MOVES TO THE PROCESS. ARE
LIKELY TO SHIP THAT WILL BE
RESOLVED IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
LEADERSHIP AND I THINK WE ALL.
LOOK FORWARD TO. ASSISTING THE
CONVERSATION AND MOVING ALONG
SO WITH THAT. ALLISTER ANY
FINAL COMMENTS SELASSIE AUTHOR
IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL. CLOSE UP
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR- SKILL IN PROVIDING.
GUIDANCE FOR US AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR- PATIENCE WITH ME
THIS AFTERNOON. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT. AND WITH THAT
WAS OUR MOTION. PRESS FOR
MOTION IS A MOTION. OF HIS
WORKS IS OUR SECOND. SACRAMENTO
KALRA. MADAM SECRETARY. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS A MENTOR FIGURES
COMEDIAN LOW GOVERNMENT TROOPS
ARE FEW HI THEY ARE NO THEY ARE
IN YEAH. AB I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. NUMBER MAIN SHOW.
MAIENSCHEIN NO QUICKSILVER I
FOLKS SILVA FIVE WEEKS FIVE
WEEKS FIVE. TO BE FIVE. FIVE
TWO I'M SORRY- FIVE TQ YOUR
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER BLUE WITH MR GRAYSON I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR- IF
YOU CAN PLEASE COME UP TO THE
PO. YOU HAVE FILE ITEM. AB.
SEVENTY FOUR. THEY ELVES ARE
SECOND. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH IS WITH WILL ALLOW
QUALIFIED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS TO EFFECTIVELY USE THE
STREAMLINED APPROVAL PROCESS
ESTABLISHED BY SB THIRTY FIVE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT
CLARIFIES A THREE YEAR SHOT
CLOCK FOR DEVELOPMENT AND
MODIFICAR MODIFICATIONS
APPROVALS PAUSED WHEN THE CITY
THROUGH THE PROJECT. IT
SPECIFIES THE PROJECT MUST ONLY
COMPLY WITH THE OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS THAT WERE IN PLACE
WHEN THE PROJECT WAS INITIALLY
APPROVED AND LASTLY AB ELEVEN
SEVEN FOUR MAKES TECHNICAL
CHAPTER AND AMENDMENTS TO
PREVIOUS SB THIRTY FIVE RELATED
BILLS THESE CHANGES WILL ENSURE
QUALIFYING HOUSING DEVELOPER
CHECKS CAN BE EFFECTIVELY
STREAM BY STREAMLINED AS
INTENDED UNDER SB THIRTY FIVE I
DO HAVE A WITNESS MISTER
MICHAEL LANE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
FOR TO GO TO MISTER LINE PLEASE.
LITERATURE MEMBERS MICHAEL IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION PUBLIC POLICY THINK
TANK KNOWN AS BURKE. SB THIRTY
FIVE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS BOON TO THE
PRODUCTION OF PORTABLE HOUSING
STREAMLINED APPROVAL TO HELP TO
BRING NEW HOMES ONLINE MORE
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY.
HOWEVER AS WITH ALL MAJOR
LANDMARK LEGISLATION THERE'S
NEED FOR CLARIFICATION THE
TACKLE CLEAN UP TO IMPLEMENT
THE LAW AN ADVANCE THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE. IS
PERFECTLY TRUE SINCE OTHER
MAJOR HOUSING LEGISLATION HAS
BEEN PASSED SUBSEQUENTLY THAT'S
IMPORTANT HARMONIZED AND
ALIGNED THESE LAWS AS WE WORK
TO PROTECT THEM. AS NOTED THE
EXPERT COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WILSHIRE
THE PROJECT SPONSOR DOES NOT
LOSE THE BENEFITS UNDER SB
THIRTY FIVE DID A LITIGATION.
THIS IS SOMEWHAT TO TOTALING
AGREEMENTS WHICH ARE COMMON AND
ENSURED THAT ONE DOES NOT
FORFEIT TIME LIMITED RIGHTS
UNDER THE LAW DUE TO THE TIME
IT TAKES FOR A LEGAL DISPUTE TO
BE SETTLED. THE BILL ALSO
CLARIFIED OF THE STATE AND
LOCAL LAWS THAT AFFECT THE TIME
WHEN THE ORIGINAL DEVELOPMENT
APPLICATION WAS SUBMITTED CHAU
ALSO BY THE SUBSEQUENT. RIGHT
TO PROJECTS SUCH AS PERMETTRA.
GRADING AND ALSO IMPROVEMENTS
THIS CLARIFICATION WILL ENSURE
THAT HOUSING STREAM PUNCH
APPALACHIAN LET'S JUST INTENDED
AND WE ARE DELIGHTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR. I CANNOT BELIEVE
THERE ARE ANY OF. WITNESSES
FROM JUST DOUBLE CHECK. NO
OPPOSITIONS WITHOUT GO TO THEM
LET'S GO TO PUBLIC- THERE'S NO
PER COMMENT IN THE ROOM. MISS
IF THEY ANY OF THE REMOTE
STATIONS. SEE NON LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO THE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANY. SUPPORTERS OR OPPONENTS
TO- FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR GRAYSON.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS YOUR
POSITION ON AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOR ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO LOCAL FIRST
ONLINE OF ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CALLER
ON LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO STATE YOUR POSITION.
WILL MOVE ONLINE ONE TWENTY
FOUR ONE TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE TWENTY FOUR IS YOUR
DEVICE NEEDED. HOME AGAIN TO
LINE TO FORTY NINE TWO FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS BOB TAYLOR I REPRESENT
SEALS SOUTHERN COMPANY IN
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
BORDERLINE ONE TWENTY TWO ONE
TWO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER SECOND
NOVEL NOT LIKE ALL PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
TMG PARTNERS CALIFORNIANS NEED
UNDERSTAND HELP PROPERTY SB AT
HOME IN THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE
COLLEGE BEFORE THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE.
TO THIRTEEN TWO THREE NINE. A
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS THE ONLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIX
FIVE TO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK TO SIXTY FIVE YOU
WANT TO STATE YOUR POSITION.
ALTHOUGH ON THE LINE TWO ZERO
SIX TWO HUNDRED SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TWO OH SIX IS YOUR
PHONE ON MUTE. SHE CAN'T REALLY
DONE I'LL BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. BORDERLINE. ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT ONE SEVEN EIGHT.
AIRPLANE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK MISTER JOURNAL FOR THE
LINES IN Q. THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR THE PROJECT- COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OUR MOTION OF THE BILL
FOR. MOTION BY HIS QUICK SILVA
SECONDED BY MR GABRIEL- THIS
GRAYSON APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
TO CONTINUE IMPROVE SB THIRTY
FIVE AND- THANK YOU WILL HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE-
GIVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
RESPECT MADAM SECRETARY MOTION
NEED TO PASS ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
LOCAL. TO FIVE TWO FIVE THEY
ARE CO GET GABBY I KALRA. ALL
RIGHT I HIGHLY HIGHLY I MAIN
SHOW MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT SILVA.
RIGHT THANKS TO BUY WEEK. HE
FIVE SIX ZERO SAN. YOUR BILL
PASSES YOU VERY MUCH GRACE. WE
WILL NOW CALL ON MISTER GAY WHO
ALONG MR BLUE HAS THE BILLS TO.
YOU THREE BILLS- FOR ITEM TEN
ELEVEN AND TWELVE WHAT IS YOUR
PLEASURE. START WHAT IS YOUR
PLEASURE WHICH BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE WE DO WELL NOT GO AND I
SEVEN SO SINCE I THAT WILL BE
QUITE. FILE ITEM- ELEVEN A.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN. THERE'S BEEN.
ARE A- THERE'S A SECOND. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AB NOW SEVEN
WITH STRENGTHEN- OVERSIGHT IT
TRANCE FOR STATE FUNDED
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS WHICH IS
A CENTRAL BOTH ADDRESSING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND
EFFECTIVELY USING TAXPAYER
RESOURCES THIS BILL BUILT ON
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR AND IS
SUPPORTED BY TAXPAYER ADVOCATES
ONLY CITY CONTROLLER RON
GALPERIN IN THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IS NOT IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM ANY IN THE REMOTE STATIONS.
TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ALLOW ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
TO SEE YOUR POSITION ON AB NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN WE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. AN
ONLINE SECURE AT THIS TIME.
WITHOUT COMING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND-
APPRECIATE- YOU MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND LET'S PROBABLY MAKE
THIS THE SHORTEST PRESENTATION
ILLUSTRATING PHONE ACCOUNTS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OUR MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN HUMAN
SERVICES- YEAH I JUST WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE THIS
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN IN THE NEXT MINUTE. MADAM
SECRETARY. TWO FIVE TWO FIVE
SEATTLE JABRI HI I KALRA ALL
RIGHT I KILEY FARLEY
MAIENSCHEIN MEAN FOR I WORKS.
THANKS TO FIVE WE. FIFTY POINT
SIXTY ZERO THE BILL PASSES ARE
WE I DON'T YOU TO TAKE A STILL.
NINE NINETY. FILE ITEM TWELVE
AB NINETY NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER TURN NUMBER AND I TO
START- THANKING YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THE ASSISTANCE ON
THIS BILL. WE TODAY PRESENTED
AS IT WOULD CREATE A
SPECIALIZED APPEAL PANEL. KNOWN
AS THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS SITUATIONS
WHERE LOCAL OFFICIALS SEEK TO
PREVENT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN VIOLATION
OF STATE LAW. LEGISLATION IS A
MODEST EFFORT TO STRENGTHEN TE
PURPOSE AND INTENT OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
INITIALLY PASSED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AIMS TO
PREVENT EFFORTS TO BLOCK THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THAT OTHERWISE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE APPLICABLES
GENERAL PLAN ZONING AND
SUBDIVISION STANDARDS REQUIRES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE
SPECIFIC FINDINGS IN THE EVENT
THEY DO SO. UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S WELL
DOCUMENTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE DEFIED THE ACT. THE
TONIGHT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS EVEN WHEN THEY ARE
FULLY COMPLIANT WITH ALL LOCAL
ZONING AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. THESE OFFICIALS
UNDERSTAND THAT IN MOST CASES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROPONENTS
WILL HAVE NO PRACTICAL MEANS TO
CHALLENGE THE UNLAWFUL DENIAL.
AS THE CURRENT REMEDY
LITIGATION IN SUPERIOR COURT.
IS ALMOST ALWAYS PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING AND
OTHERWISE IMPRACTICAL. AB
NINETY NINE WOULD ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM BY CREATING ALTERNATE
REVIEW PANEL WITH SPECIALIZED
EXPERTISE. IMPORTANTLY THE
JURISDICTION OF THE REVIEW
PANEL WOULD BE VERY NARROW AND
WHETHER THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
VIOLATED THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. BUT JUST
APPROVING A PROJECT WITHOUT
MAKING APPROPRIATE FINDINGS AS
REQUIRED BY LAW. THE PANEL
WOULD BEST BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES AROUND THE IMPROPER
AND UNLAWFUL DEMANDS OF
AFFORDABLE HANDING. IN A MORE
EXPEDITED LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
CONFRONTATIONAL AND MORE
CONSISTENT MANNER. TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES A NEW
PROCEDURAL REMEDY TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES IT DOES NOT OBSERVE ON
CHANGING THE LOCAL ZONING OR
LAND USE POLICIE. OR OTHERWISE
CHANGE SUBSTANTIVE STATE LAW
AROUND HOUSING. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO FOLLOW STATE
LAW IN GOOD FAITH ARE HIGHLY
UNLIKELY TO HAVE ANY
INTERACTION WITH THIS NEW
REVIEW PANEL. WELL THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY AND
WILLFULLY VIOLATING THE LAW
WILL BE ENCOURAGED TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. THIS LESS
ADVERSARIAL AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE SUPPORT APPROACH IS
SUPPORTED BY. A BROAD COALITION
OF HOUSING GROUPS ADVOCATES AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING COURT
CONSORTIUM. THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR ROLE HOUSING
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY OR TWENTY BILLION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND MARK STIVERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU AND
WEBER KRESSLEY RESPECT AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ARE OUR FIRST
ONE IS I THINK IS ON THE LINE
TO THE MOVIE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. MISTER BERRY YES I
AM. THANK YOU AGAIN TWENTY
WOULD BE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
WHICH IS A KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF. I'M SORRY MADE BY LAWFUL-
AT THE OFFICE. AB EIGHT NINE
NINETY NOT TAKING TO WAY
BOASTING ALSO BE CRAZY TO FOR
THREE A REJECT DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT IS. WITH THE REJECTION
WAS DONE IN THE COURSE CURRENT
LAW. AND THREE PER TODAY TODAY
THE STATE CAN HELP YOU QUIT YOU
ARGUE TO LACK AND THAT MANY HOW
A CHANCE GOOD PAST. HOUSING
GRETCHEN'S BACK THREE YEARS
HOPE SO THE CRISIS AT HAND
VISIBLE A TOOL TRICK WITH.
HOUSING PRODUCTION OR BOOKS
TODAY- AT THE TO STEP WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT QUALITY CRIMES
HOW ALL THE BILL WOULD NOT BE
AN ISSUE HELLO. AND WHAT BETTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE
TIME COME. THAT ARE ON
WELCOMING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- THE PARTNERSHIP HERE'S
MY DEVELOPERS THEY WILL DOES
NOT TAKE THE FINANCIAL RISK TO
BUY A PROPERTY IF THEY DON'T
THINK THEY CAN GET THROUGH THE
LOCAL DEPARTMENT PROCESS- WHILE
THE EXISTING HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IN THREE
PROTECT DEVELOPER FROM
ARBITRARY DENIALS ARE
UNREASONABLE CONDITIONS. IT IS
A RELATIVELY EMPTY PROTECTION
VERY FEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS WILL SPEND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
LEGAL FEES INTEREST AND
ADDITIONAL CARRYING COSTS AND
AT LEAST TWO YEARS IN COURT-
TO- OTHER TIME TO GO THROUGH
THE COURTS. THIS ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEALS BODY CONCEPT HAS BEEN
TRIED AND FOUND SUCCESSFUL IN
MASSACHUSETTS WHERE IT'S BEEN
IN PLACE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE RHODE ISLAND ILLINOIS AND
OREGON. OUR DEVELOPERS TELL IN
AB EIGHT NINE EIGHTY NINE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE RISK
PROFILE OF GIVING THEM GREATER
CERTAINTY AND CONFIDENCE TO
BRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROPOSALS FORWARD AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY GET THEM BUILT. AB
NINETY NINE IS ABOUT EFFICIENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THERE IS NO MAN
OPPOSITION WITNESS. WHY DON'T
WE GO TO. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE WHICH HAS BECOME PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. GOING TO
THE REMOTE- STATION THERE'S NO
ONE THE REMOTE STATION- THERE
IS SOMEONE VERY NO WORRIES MISS.
YOU KNOW I WOULD BE CAL HOUSING.
AND THANK YOU GOING TO THE
REMOTE STATIONS. GOING OUT TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FORCE.
OR OPPONENTS AB NOW NINE
GABRIEL. HE DOES YOUR BUSY ON A
NINE EIGHTEEN. MAY PRESS AND
THEN ZERO YOUR TO. THAT'S
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO WE'LL GO
FIRST ONLINE OF. TO FORTY TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT PICK ME FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE.
TO TWO ZERO ZERO. NINE TWO
HUNDRED IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
MOVE THE LINE TO SEVENTY FOUR
TWO SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BLIND. TWO SEVEN THREE TO
SEVENTY THREE. TWO SEVENTY
THREE ARE YOU ON ME. BUDGETARY
NUMBERS OUT OF STORAGE WITH
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF THE HOW CAN I HELP SUPPORT.
NEXT TO ONE FIFTH EIGHT ONCE
EIGHT. HI JACKIE IF ON THE OF
HOUSING HELP WE'RE SUPPORT OF
AB NINE EIGHT AS WELL AS AB
SEVENTY ONE ONE FIFTEEN I WAS
UNABLE GET AND THE QUEUE EARLY
ON THE BILL ALL BUT- THANK YOU.
NEXT WE ARE MIND TWO ZERO SIX
TWO SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON DONE
NOT OF THE BUILDING ASSN. AND
THANK YOU NO FURTHER ALONG IN
Q. THIS TIME. THANKS VERY MUCH
WELL LET'S BRING TO THE CA FROM.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL FOR THIS IS A IDEA
BEEN LOOKING OUT FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS- SAN- IT. IS MODELED
AFTER AND THAT HAS BEEN SO IN
STATE ON EAST COAST-
MASSACHUSETTS. WHERE I GREW UP
RYLAN ILLINOIS. AND AND WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT- THIS PAN
CAN RESERVE CAN RESOLVE
DISPUTES. ARE AROUND THE
UNLAWFUL OR IMPROPER DENIAL OF
HOUSING IN A MORE EXPEDITED
LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
CONFRONTATIONALAND MORE
CONSISTENT MANNER I THINK IT'S
DEFINITELY WORTHY OF OUR
CONSIDERATION WITH THAT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT MOVING THIS FOR. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. MR KILEY. I
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL I I'D TOOK
COME QUESTIONS IS YOUR
INTENTION THE HEARINGS THIS-
BOB- IF CREATED WITH OPENED UP
YEAH ABSOLUTELY OKAY- AND SO OF
MY CONCERNS IS WITH THE
COMPOSITION OF- THE OF THE
BOARD I THINK RIGHT NOW YOU
HAVE BUT IT'S FIVE MEMBERS
THREE APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
ONE IS WITH OPR AND ONES WITH
EACH CD. SO IT KIND OF SEEMS
LIKE WERE CONSOLIDATING WATER
AUTHORITY IN THE I KNOW YOU DO
OF ONE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR RIGHT ONE WE HAVE
ONE LOCAL GOVERNMENT REPRESENT
RIGHT REFUSING ONE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVE ONE
WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EXPERIENCE AND THEN FROM THE
STATE WE HAVE OPR EACH CD AND
ONE FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
GOT IT WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO
HAVING SOMEONE ON THERE WHO
WOULD SORT OF BE A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE LESS
POPULATED- CITIES AND COUNTIES
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
MAYBE- CITIES AND COUNTIES WITH
UNDER HER THOUSAND PEOPLE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. YEAH I'D
I'D VERY MUCH BE OPEN TO HAVING
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT- I
THINK I'D WANT TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY I'D WANT TO GET SOME
FEEDBACK FROM OUR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHAIR HOPEFULLY IF
IT GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE I
KNOW THAT THAT'S A PASSION FOR
HER IT'S MAKING FOR THE ROLE
CALIFORNIANS REPRESENTED SO
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT OKAY.
AND IF- A DECISION OF A LOCAL
AGENCY WERE REVERSED- THIS BILL
WOULD NOT STOP THE MUNICIPALITY
OR THE LOCAL AGENCY FROM THAN
TRYING TO- IN JOIN- THAT
REVERSAL IN COURT I ASSUME
THEY'RE BE AN AVENUE OF THAT
I'VE REFERRED YOU JUST REVIEW
AVAILABLE STELLAR I THAT'S YES
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD BE MY UNDER- YOU KNOW YOU
YOU WANT TO LOS THAN I DID SO I
MIGHT. TURN I DON'T KNOW THAT
OUT AROUND AND BUT YOU KNOW
HERE REMOVED THE JURISDICTION
OF THE CAR I THAT YOU KNOW IF
THEY IF THEY'RE WERE SOMETHING
THAT THE LOCAL GUY WANTED TO
THERE ARE- OR SOME OTHER
PROCESS THINK THAT THEY THE UP
TO DO. OKAY. AND YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE CONCERNS YOU ALWAYS HAVE
WHEN SOME. BORDERS CREATED BY
THE- THAN YOU'RE KIND OF ONE
IT'S THERE THAT HAVE BECOME.
SORT OF A- ATTEMPTING YOU KNOW
VIEW. FOR A COUPLE OTHER TH.
RIGHT AND IT'S- YOU KNOW. WE
CAN. IT TO. WAYS TO- TAKE A-
YOU KNOW. CONTROL WAY IS JUST
ONE OF CORD YOU'RE INTO. THE
ALL. THAT THIS BOY. ONLY
PURPOSE BE FOR THE PURPOSE. IN
THIS. 100% IN THE CHURCH. OF
BILL IS THE- THE- OF THE UP A
REVIEW. SIX LIMITED. THE BILL
THEY CAN BE- ONLY GETTING
ANSWER QUESTION- AND IT'S A-
NARROW QUESTION CLEAR THE THEY
DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO GO
BEYOND. THAT AND I. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT INTEREST TO ME IN
OUR OUR CALL. THE CHAIR THIS
COMMITTEE. OUT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO. IN ANY. ANOTHER IT
HEALTH DECISION THESE CAN
ACTUALLY YOU- THAT OFTEN. WHEN
THERE'S AN APPEAL. I THINK IT'S
ONLY 18% OF THE- IN MATH. DID
STEP AT THE REVIEW. IF DECISION.
AND THE OTHER. EIGHTY TWO. OF
THE PARTY REACHED INTO. SO THE
IDEA HERE IS NOT AT ALL TO- TO
SURPLUS CONFRONTS HIM IS VERY
SO. TO IT OF LOCAL. THE IDEA
HERE IS CURRENT THERE REALLY IS
NO RENDON. AS AS AS AS ONE OF
THE- TO. AND SO. THIS PROVIDE
AN INSIGHT. ON THE FRONT AND
PEOPLE TO GET TOGETHER. TO HAVE
OUT THERE TO. AND HOPEFULLY TO-
TO PROVIDE FOLKS WITH RENDON'S.
TO DO RIGHT THING. WELL I'M NOT.
CHEST FOR TODAY- I. TO THE I.
HERE AND- YOU KNOW HOPE THAT
YOU ALL. IT CONTINUE TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE.
SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE WHEN
THE BILLS AND IT'S WONDERFUL.
ABSOLUTELY CHECK THAT. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. WITHOUT THAT
YOU'VE ALMOST LOST MY VOTE
BECAUSE YOU'VE CONCEDED THAT
YOU'LL LAW SCHOOL MIGHT BE A
BETTER LAW SCHOOL AND HARVARD
BUT PUTTING THAT ASIDE TO THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU MR TERRORIST
THE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY. ALL. MADAM SECRETARY
I NEED TO CLARIFY HAVE WE DO
MOTION TO THE BY FAR WE DID IS
OUR MOTION THE BILL. THERE'S A
ARE SECOND. THERE'S UNANSWERED
THERE TO. THANK YOU. OUR MOTION
TO. DO PASSED TO THE- COMEDIAN
LOW GOVERNMENT TRUE RIGHT. FEW
I SAY ARE. TWO ZERO HOUSES AND-
WITHOUT I THINK THERE'S ONLY
ONE MORE BILL YOU'VE GOT
FRIGHTENED TEN AB SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN THAT- PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL ENDEAVOR
AGAIN TO BE QUICK- AND I DO
WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR THE REALLY HARD WORK
HARD WORK ON THIS AND THE WAY
IN WHICH THEY BROUGHT THE
PARTIES TOGETHER HERE AND WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. WHICH I I'M
GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF THE- THE
FOLKS WHO WEIGHED IN ON THE
PROCESS TO GET US TO A BETTER
PLACE I'M PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL EMPOWERS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PRESERVE
MIDDLE INCOME WORKFORCE HOUSING
WHICH I BELIEVE IS ESSENTIAL TO
ADDRESSING OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS AND ENSURING THAT
WORKING FAMILIES FIREFIGHTERS
NURSES TEACHERS POLICE OFFICERS
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY WORK AND
SERVE. AND THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
RECEIVE ARENA CREDIT FOR
CONVERTING MARKET RATE UNITS TO
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS WHICH ONE CENTER BY THE
LONG TERM PRESERVATION OF LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
ACQUIRING AND CONVERTING
EXISTING UNITS IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPLEMENT TO ANY PRODUCTION
FOR STRATEGY AND OFFERS A
CHEAPER FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT WAY TO INCREASE
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING YOU
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR
MICHAEL UP HERE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY HOUSING
AGENCY AND MICHAEL LANE FROM
SPUR AND WOULD REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU LET'S TURN IT OVER TO
THE TO MICHAEL'S- TO MIKE
LAPIERRE FIRST. PLEASE GREAT
THANK VERY MUCH AND GOOD AT.
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO THE- ABC EIGHTY SEVEN- NOTED
MY NAME IS MICHAEL. ARE THE K.
COMMITTED HOUSING AGENCY. KNOWN
AS CAL. MOVIES BY. THE BEFORE
YOU TODAY. THAT TIME WHEN
CALLUM. STATE FINANCIAL.
RELATED BE ON GO TO COPE
NINETEEN. HEALTH CRISIS.
CONFISCATE HOUSING. AND THE
PERSON THREAT OF DISPLACEMENT
WE NEED INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
DRIVE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY FOR
ALL. COUNTY WAS FORMED FOR THE
SOLE PURPOSE. OF ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING
AFFORDABILITY AND MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING CRISIS. CAL TO UTILIZE
HIS REVENUES GENERATED FROM THE
SALE OF ITS GOVERNMENTAL
PURPOSE SPOT. TO FULLY FINANCE
THE ACQUISITION AND CONVERSION
OF EXISTING MARKET RATE
APARTMENT COMMUNITIES TO RENT
RESTRICTED HOUSING FOR
HOUSEHOLDS EARNING. AT OR BELOW
A 120% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. THIS IS A QUICKLY TO
HOUSING FOR SOCIAL WORKERS SUCH
AS NURSES TEACHERS FIRST
RESPONDERS LIBRARIANS SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT LIKELY KERN TOO
MUCH. TO QUALIFY FOR
TRADITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAMS. THAT AT 60% OR BELOW
AREA MEDIAN INCOME. THAT WAS IT
AS A RESULT THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ARE SUBJECT TO EVER
INCREASING MARKET RATE HOUSING.
AND MANY ARE NOT ABLE TO LIVE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE. THROUGHOUT COUNTY
EXISTENCE WE CAN'T UNDERSTAND
THERE WAS NO METHOD FOR HITTING.
TO COME CREDIT THESE TYPES OF
MARKET RATE CONVERT. THAT AB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
PROVIDE CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH A MODEST PATHWAY TO
RECEIVING CREDIT. IN THEIR
ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS FOR THE
CONVERSION OF MARKET RATE UNITS
TO DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS. THAT INCENTIVIZE THE
LONG TERM PRESERVATION UP LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
WHILE GUARANTEEING LOW TERM.
LONG TERM AFFORDABILITY AND
RENTER PROTECTIONS. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION ON THIS BILL THIS
AFTERNOON AND SPECIAL THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND HIS
TEAM. FOR THEIR CONTENT
CONTINUE. TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU LET'S CONFIRM LANE.
MAKE SURE MEMBERS MICHAEL THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY PLANNING
URBAN REESE SAYS. A PUBLIC
POLICY THINK TANK KNOWN AS FOR
IS TO THE BILL HOW CAL AND
DEALS ARE COLOR. A SINGLE
NUCLEAR BROWN HOUSING IN OUR CO
AREAS CAN COST UP TO EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR MORE. WE
JUST NEED TO INNOVATE AND NEW
APPROACHES THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY
HELP HEALTH AFFORDABLE LAUREN
HOUSE I AREA. FOR WE ALSO NEED
TO PRODUCE MORE HOUSING FOR
COST BURDENED BY INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS DON'T FALL LITTLE
MOST OF FOR HOUSING. AND YET
STRUGGLE TO COMPETE FOR AVAIL
MARKET HOUSING. DOING SO
BUILDING TYPES CONSTRUCTION
METHODS FINANCING MODELS THAT
CAN REDUCE THE COST. PROVIDE
GREATER REPORTED WOULD NOT. ARE
RELATIVELY SHALLOW SAID. WE
OFTEN ACQUISITION. EXIT
BUILDING COST THAN HALF OF NEW
CAN. THE RENT AND THEN BECAME
AND PROPERTY OVER TO GREATER
REPORTER. I NEED YOUR ACROSS
THE REPORT MORE INCOME UNITS
ONE THEIR ANNUAL YOUR STATE CD.
AB SEVENTY SEVEN WILL PROVIDE A
WAY TO IT THIS TO. AMERICANS
THANK YOU. AND WITH LET'S GO
NOW TO. PUBLICADA FIRST IN THE
HEARING OR IS WHY IT. THREE IN
A WHITE WITH THE CAL HOUSING IN
SUPPORT AND LET'S TO THE REMOTE
STAY. SYNONYMOUS TO THE
OPERATOR ONE. THIS IS FOR
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND STE OF
UP TO AB SEVEN HR. KEENEST YOUR
POSITION ON AB SEVENTEEN SEVEN
PRESS FOR BY THE ON YOUR KEYPAD.
THERE'S ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT AS WE PROVIDE THE
LINE NUMBER TO THEM. OUR COMMON
COMES FROM MINE TO SEVENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JESSIE CALMLY FROM THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP. WE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. NORTHERN
ALLIANCE SECURITIES TIME THANK
YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT HE AND
HIS STAFF TOOK TO ENGAGE WITH
OUR STAFF AS WELL AS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY
THAT HAD. INITIALLY BEEN
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION I THINK
WE'RE ALL SUPPORTIVE OF
INNOVATIVE MODELS TO CONVERT
NON AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE AGREED
TO TAKE WILL ENSURE THAT ONE
CITIES GET RENEW CREDIT FOR
THIS THERE ARE APPROPRIATE
GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE. THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT AND WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
MISTER ANY FINAL COMMENTS. IS
EMOTIONAL FOR. THEIR SECOND.
AND THE LET ME ASK YOU OFF ANY
FINAL YEAH I JUST WANT TO A
AGAIN A MY THING TO MR FOR THE
FOR THE FOR TAKING A CHANCE TO
GIVE THE TIME THE OPPORTUNITY
SPACE TO HAVE THE TOP AND THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR THEIR HELP- IN
CONCERT WORKED US SORT THAT I'M
GOING WE GOT EVERY IN THE SAME
PLACE AND WITH RESPECT REQUEST
AND- GREAT- WITHOUT MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION TO PASS AS A
MAN. TO THE S. COME. LOOK TO.
CHIU BY SHOE I THEY ARE. THERE
ARE NO I'D GIVE HI CAN RELY
KALRA. KALRA KILEY. HIGHLY I
MAIENSCHEIN. WORKS. COURTESY OF
A WEEKS. SIXTY ZERO ZERO YOUR
BILL PASSES THE CALLER I WILL
LET YOU KNOW WE THREE ITEMS
LEFT- ITEM BY SOME MEMBER
CARILLO MISTER MALL OF MICE I
BE PRISON ALL THREE. DO TO THE
OUR THIS LATE DAY AT THE END OF
WEEK- AND- I WILL ASK OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE TO US SO WE CAN
GO THE ROLE ONE. AND TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
OUR THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
ON PRESENTING TO BILLS YOU FOR
PRESENTING TO AND OF A ASSEMBLY
CARILLO. ARE WE READY FOR ITEM
NINE AB SIX THIRTY FOUR. PROUD
TO PRESENT THIS ON BEHALF
ASSEMBLY CARILLO- AB SIX THIRTY
FOUR WILL HELP ADDRESS THE OF.
HOUSING BY ALLOWING LOW
GOVERNMENTS TO EXT THE
AFFORDABLE TERM. FOR FUTURE
UNITS THAT QUALIFY EIGHT FOR
DENSITY BONUS BE FIFTH FIVE YOU.
CURRENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REQUIRED TO ADOPTING. HOUSING
OR- BUT UNDER LAW IF IT IS
SUBJECT AND- SET ASIDE
REQUIREMENTS. AND THE DEVELOPER
TO USE THE BY PROGRAM YOU. TO
RAISE FOR RENTALS ASIDE ON BOTH
OF PROGRAM WOULD BE FOR FIVE
YEARS. IN SOME LOCAL.
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCES
REQUIRE LONGER AFFORDABILITY
COVENANTS THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS
THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY THAT
FOR UNITS IN DEVELOPMENT
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE.
BEFORE WELL THE COVENANT CAN BE
LONGER THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS IF
THE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE REQUIRES A LONGER
PERIOD WITH THAT WILL TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WITNESS. ANY
BIOTECH WITH THE LA DEPARTMENT
OF REGIONAL PLANNING. WE JUST
HAVE THE ONE WITNESS ON THE
PHONE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AFFECT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON ON EIGHTY SIX THREE
FOUR. MY NAME IS AMY THIRD ACT
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
REGIONAL PLANTING PLANNING. FOR
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. AND
I AM SEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THANK YOU ALSO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC. BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT
THERE IS A HOUSING CRISIS
ACROSS THE STATE WHICH IS NO
LESS ACUTE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
TAKEN DRAMATIC STEPS TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS IN THE COUNTY'S
UNINCORPORATED AREAS. ADOPTING
LANDMARK POLICIES INCLUDING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRESERVATION
ORDINANCE. IT BY RIGHT HOUSING
ORDINANCE. INTERMENT THE PART
OF HOUSING. A PER. DENSITY
ORDINANCE COULD BE STATE
REQUIRED. AND THE AND- AMENDED
INCLUSION HOUSING ORDINANCE
SHTICK IS A LOW AND- HOUSING
ORDINANCE WORK. THAT THE
HOUSING. IN RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS BE AFFORDABLE IN
PERPETUITY. HOWEVER AS NOTED IF
THE DEVELOPER WANTED TO PAIR
THE COUNTY'S INCLUSIONARY
REQUIREMENTS. WITH THE STATE'S
DENSITY BONUS LAW THEN THE
AFFORDABILITY DURATION FOR
THOSE SAME UNITS UNDER THE
PROGRAMS WOULD BE LIMITED. TO
FIFTY FIVE YEARS. THIS BILL.
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES LOCAL
JR. THE OP. TO EXTEND COVENANTS
BEYOND FIFTY FIVE YEARS
PROVIDING A CRITICAL TOOL TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. WHICH THIS
BILL DOES NOT AFFECTED
JURISDICTIONS SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING NOR DOES IT CREATE A
FINANCIAL BURDEN TO ANY
MUNICIPALITY. ALLOWING OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO EXTEND
AFFORDABILITY TERMS FOR FUTURE
UNITS CREATED UNDER BOTH LOCAL
AND STATE HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR
LONGER THAN FIFTY YEARS WHAT
RESULT IN LONGER TERM
AFFORDABILITY AND ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE TO
PRESERVE THEIR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK. FOR A LONGER
TERM. IT'S A SIMPLE FIX BUT ONE
THAT WOULD HAVE FAR REACHING
POSITIVE BENEFITS. IN
STABILIZING OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AVAILABILITY IN SHORT
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL AND I REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTES IN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND THANK YOU
OUR NEXT UP WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I DO
BELIEVE SO- WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND OPEN UP TO. COMMENTS
FROM ARMY NO WITNESSES- FROM
THE RIVER THE- COMMITTEE ROOM
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES FROM
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. ABOUT OUR
REMOTE LOCATION. IF NOT
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES- ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT-
PLEASE REMEMBER JUST YOUR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
AND WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT THE BILL. RT IF YOU
LIKE TO STATE YOUR POSITION. IF
YOU LIKE STABILIZATION AND AMY
SIX THREE FOUR ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THE COMMANDOS
ONE FOR BY THE UNDER TO KEYPAD.
Q. THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN- IN
QUEUES WILL BRING ABOUT TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. AND NOT LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE ANYBODY WHO HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SO- DID
YOU WANT TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. VERY GOOD YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. PORTION OF.
I WILL SECOND WE HAVE A MOST BY
KIRK SILVA AND AN ASSET BY Q.
YOU MAY END CALDERON. THE
MOTION TO SYSTEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY CAN LOW GOVERNMENT
ISSUE- THEY ARE TO KNOW. NO
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I CALLED. ALL
RIGHT I. KILEY I ONLY KNOW
MAIENSCHEIN WORKS HI FOR
SURVIVE. DO YOU HOME THAT. OKAY
SO THAT'LL STILL OPEN AND WILL
UNTIL- IN A MEETING. ALL RIGHT-
NEXT UP WE BELIEVE WE HAVE A.
B. TEN TWENTY NINE FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MALEN BEING
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
RESTRICT YOU YOU CAN GO AHEAD
THANK YOU THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN COLLEAGUES ONE OF THE
LESSER KNOWN CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE SHORTAGE OF HOUSING AND OUR
STATE HAS BEEN THE EXPIRATION
OF AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS.
WHEN OUR STATE HAD
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
AGENCY OR REQUIRED TO RECORD
COVENANTS ON LAND THAT WOULD
GUARANTEE THAT UNITS WOULD
REMAIN AFFORDABLE AT BELOW
MARKET RATES FOR THIRTY AND IN
SOME INSTANCES FIFTY YEARS BUT
OVER THE YEARS MANY OF THOSE
COVENANTS HAVE REACHED THOSE
TIME LIMITS AND EXPIRED AND HAS
EXPIRED THE UNIT MAY THEN BE
LEASED AT MARKET RATE. AS EACH
UNIT RECESSED TO THE MARKET
THAT'S ONE LESS AFFORDABLE
UNITS AVAILABLE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THIS BILL ASKS EIGHT
CD TO ADD CODE TO THE
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS TO THEIR LIST OF
PRIORITIES FOR THE ALLOCATION
OF STATE FUNDING WE KNOW IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO SAVE UNIT FROM
CONVERTING TO MARKET RATE THAN
TO BUILD A BRAND NEW ONE THIS
IS A SIMPLE YET IMPORTANT STATE
STEP TO. ENSURING THAT WE ARE
MAINTAINING OUR SCARCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK AND WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
TODAY THE MAYOR OF FOSTER CITY
SAN DIEGO HUNTING AND A
RESIDENT OF FOSTER'S LANDING
BARBER GROCERY. YEAH WE HAVE A
MOTION TO GABRIEL IN THE SECOND
HALF BY. IT WAS A OKAY. BECAUSE
OF THE COLOR. ARE NOT GO AHEAD
AND GO TO ROOM CAN GO TO THE
FIRST. AND AE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MR VICE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SANJAY
GANDHI I'M THE MAYOR OF FOSTER
CITY. ALL BEGIN BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
PREPARING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. WASHINGTON IS
LOCATED IN THE MID PENINSULA OF
THE BAY AREA. WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED OUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARE PROUD TO
BE THE TOP 5% OF CITIES IN THE
STATE. WHEN IT COMES TO MEETING
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING TARGETS.
WHATEVER HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
FOSTER'S LANDING WAS BUILT IN
THE MID NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
INCLUDED SEVENTY FOUR BELOW
MARKET RATE RENTAL UNITS. THE
PMR RESTRICTIONS WERE SET TO
EXPIRE IN PHASES STARTING WITH
FIFTY UNITS EXPIRING AT THE END
OF LAST YEAR. I WITH THE FINAL
PHASE EXPIRING AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. FOR THE
THIRTY UNITS THAT WERE SET TO
EXPIRE LAST YEAR THE CITY AND
THE PROPERTY OWNER AGREED TO
EXTEND AFFORDABLE RENTS TO THE
PEACE ONE TENANTS UNTIL
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. THE CITY ALLOCATED FUNDS
TO PAY ITS SHARE OF THIS
PROGRAM. HOWEVER AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR THE RESIDENTS IN THE
PMR UNITS APOSTAS LANDING WILL
SEE THEIR MONTHLY RENT INCREASE
FROM FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS. THE BOSTON HAS
TAKEN SEVERAL STEPS TO ASSIST
THE TENANTS OF FOSTER'S LADY
AND ALL RESIDENTS ARE CITY. WHO
LIVE IN OR ARE LOOKING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE BAY AREA HAVE EXTREMELY
LOW TURNOVER AND A VERY LONG
WEIGHTLESS. AB TEN TWENTY NINE
WOULD BETTER POSITION THE CITY
TO COMPLETE COMPETE FOR FUNDS
THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. AN EFFORT TO SECURE A
LONG TERM FUNDING SOURCE FOR
FOSTER'S LAND. WELL HOUSING
PRODUCTION IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE. THE
PRESERVATION OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IS AN
EQUALLY IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN
ENSURING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS ARE NOT DISPLACED.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
EFFORTS WE'VE MADE IMPOSTER
CITY I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU
MISTER GET HONEY- IF THE
MODERATOR CAN OPEN LINE FOR
WITNESS NUMBER TWO BARBER
DIVERSITY. A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BARBARA
CHRISTIE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MALIK
SHRINK IT IS IN THIS IMPORTANT%
LEGISLATION THAT WILL PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AND TOXICITY. I AM
INTERESTED IN A DOCTOR'S NEED
FOR FOUR YEARS AND A RESIDENT
OF FOSTER CITY FOR OVER FORTY
FIVE YEARS WHEN THE RENTAL
MARKET DEPLETED I WAS NO LONGER
ABLE TO PAY MARKET RATE WHICH
THIS LED ME TO THE BELOW MARKET
RATE APARTMENTS. I WAS
FORTUNATE TO MOVE INTO AN
APARTMENT APPALACHIA'S LADY.
AFTER BEING ON WAITING FOR SIX
YEARS. AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. BELOW MARKET
RATE RESIDENTS WERE PROVIDED
NOTICE. THAT THE CONFIDENCE
WE'RE GOING TO EXPIRE AND ARE
HEALTHY WOULD BE GOING TO
MARKEDLY. INCREASE IN OUR BACK
AS MUCH AS THREE HUNDRED
PERCENT. MANY OF THE RESIDENTS
ARE HE LIKE MYSELF LET ME KNOW
WHAT'S UP. ALONG WITH. THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN MEMBERS WITH. A
SINGLE PARENT WITH. A FEW SHORT
MY LATER ENTIRE. FOUND
THEMSELVES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CAN'T GET AND IN ALREADY
TROUBLING SITUATION FOR US. YOU
CAN'T DESPERATE. THANK THE CITY
OF LOS CITY THAT THE
CORPORATION CAME TO AGREEMENT.
TO ALLOW CONNECTED ADDITIONAL
YEAR HOWEVER. EVEN WITH THE
ADDITIONAL YEAR OPTIONS I THINK
CURRENTLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS IN THE AREA NOW HAVE WAIT.
BY CHANCE. BECAUSE WE ARE
RESIDENTS OF PARTY CITY WE ARE
PLACED ON THE LOWEST HERE IN
EVERY OTHER CITY. OTHER VIDEO
MARKET RATE UNITS IN FOSTER
CITY HAVE PLAYED THE TIRE OF
THEIR WEIGHT. BUT THEIR COSTS
ARE TRIPLE. OUR CURRENT. I
RESULT MOVING INTO ANOTHER FOR
WHITE HOUSE COMPLEX IN NOT AT
ALL. WE ARE FOR THAT THIS IS
COUNCIL BUT IT CAN H. YOU GOT
DISPLACEMENT BUT OUR TIME IS
READY OUT. ANY OF THE TO HER NO
WORK HOME. AB TECH TO NINE WILL
SAID LIKE BY CITY AND
DEVELOPERS. AND OTHER TOOLS TO
ENSURE A PORTAL HOUSING STATE
AFFORDABLE. I'M YOU FOR LOW ME
TO SPEAK TODAY AND I ENCOURAGE
YOUR ARTICLE. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME A BRING ABOUT TO THE
COMMUTER IF THERE'S A- IN THE-
ROOM WHICH IS TO SPEAK ON THIS.
AT HE STEPPED. AND NOT APPEAR
WE HAVE ANY ANYBODY AT THE
REMOTE LOCATION. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY THERE AT THIS TIME OKAY
AS THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THAT MAIN LINE FOR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL. AND
BY PLEASE BE RAMPANT PLEASE
REMEMBER- YEAH TO YOU WE JUST
NEED YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME.
THAT ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
AND WHAT DO YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE. WHEN OPEN THE MAIN LINE
OUR MODERATOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION IN
AB TEN TWENTY NINE WE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
WHICH AGAIN THAT'S ONE FALL BY
ZERO. ON THE FIRST IN LINE TO
EIGHTY ONE TWO EIGHT ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARED MEMBERS DANE HUTCHINGS
WITH THE READING PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP- CALLING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF BELMONT
IN CARLSBAD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WEEK OR NEXT. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR NINE TWO EIGHT
FOUR. THE JURY MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOUR
NEXT BIGGER. POLYKLEITOS YES
WILL GO ONLINE TO SIXTY TWO TWO
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARLENE COMPASSIONATE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR WITH A
PRETTY UP OPPORTUNITY HERE TO-
EXPRESSED MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WEEK OR SO FOR THEM
I AM. NOT FOR THE LINE THANK
YOU FOR COLLEGES AND THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE IN THE QUEUE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
GABRIEL A SECOND BY KALRA. SO
CAN YOU GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL I'M SORRY MR CHU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AT APPRECIATE
YOUR ADULT ALL RIGHT. GOING
CALDERON THANK YOU. MOTION TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TROOPS BY Q.
FIVE K. ARGUE. GABRIEL THE
PORTLAND ACTUALLY. KALRA
CHOLERA RIGHT KALRA AYE KILEY.
I KNOW MAIENSCHEIN CORK SILVA
OKAY KIRK SILVA I WEEKS. PLEASE.
FIFTY S. KNOWS NO YOU. NINE
THREE THREE TWO THREE TWO ZERO
OKAY SO WHEN WE SAY EVEN THAT
ONE UNTIL THE END GENERAL'S.
YEAH CORRECT YOU'RE RIGHT THANK
YOU SO WE HAVE FEET ONE WITH A
SEVENTY FIVE KILEY BE- BEING
AND ALL. OKAY HOLD FOR HIM TO
MEET THANK YOU SIR ALL RIGHT-
MR CHU EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN.
FEBRUARY THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THE FINAL BILL OF THE DAY AB
TWO FIFTEEN. TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS THE
LEGISLATURE'S MADE CLEAR THAT
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS A PARTY
BY OVERHAULING THE HOUSING
ELEMENT PROCESS TO ENSURE LOCAL
POLICIES ALIGN WITH OUR STATE'S
GOAL OF SUPPORTING PRODUCTION
WHILE PROVIDING CITIES AND
COUNTIES FLEXIBILITY TO FIND
STRATEGIES THAT WORK. THIS BILL
MAINTAINS THAT LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY BUT ENSURES LOCAL
PLANTS ARE EFFECTIVE IN
PRODUCING HOUSING AND INCREASES
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THREE WAYS
FIRST REQUIRE CITIES TO HAVE A
MID CYCLE CONSULTATION WITH
EXCEEDING. IF THEIR OVERALL
HOUSING PRODUCTION IS UNDER THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE A TIMELY
COURSE CORRECTIONS. SECOND A
CITY WHOSE PRODUCTION IS
SUBSTANTIALLY BELOW THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ADOPT LOCAL
POLICIES THAT ENABLE IT TO
RECEIVE A PRO HOUSING
DESIGNATION BY EIGHTY. THIRD
THE BILL WOULD ADD THE HOUSING
CRISIS ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN
TO THE LIST OF STATE HOUSING
LAWS THAT THE AG CAN ENFORCE.
THESE STRATEGIES WILL BETTER
ENSURE THE ALIGNMENT OF STATE
LOCAL GOALS TOWARD THE CREATION
OF HOUSING AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS. THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY WIDE COALITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADVOCATES AND OTHER
INTERESTS AND HOUSING WHO ARE
WHO ARE DEDICATED TO SEEN. THE
COST OF HOUSING BECOME MORE
ATTAINABLE WITHOUT A LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO A WITNESS MS
MARINO Y. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM GET ME OF
THE ONE WITNESS MARINO WAIT
TESTIFYING IN PERSON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MARINO MY THE
CALIFORNIA HAS A CONSORTIUM WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN
WHICH INCREASES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF CITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
AND EFFECTIVE AT FACILITATING
PRODUCTION. BUILDING ON THE
EFFORTS OF AB SEVENTY TWO OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH WE ALSO
CO SPONSORED AB. TWO FIFTEEN
TAKES ANOTHER IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS ENSURING EVERY REGION
IS MAKING. TO MEETING HOUSING
GOALS THIS I JUST THAT IMPROVE
IMPROVE THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
KEEP TABS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION IT WILL ALSO OFFER
TIMELY TARGETED SUPPORT TO
JURISDICTIONS FALLING BEHIND
THEIR HOUSING TARGETS. HELPING
EVERY COMMUNITY STAY ON TRACK
TO BILL THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS. FOR THESE REASONS
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND IT DOES NOT
APPEAR WE HAVE ANY- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SO AT THIS TIME
I WILL. ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM. DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE SO
ANYBODY ON THEIR REMOTE
LOCATION. DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
WE HAVE ANYBODY THERE SO IT IS
TIME TO THE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL I REMEMBER WE JUST NEED
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT. AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. OUR
MODERATOR GO IN OPEN YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
YOU'RE MY COULD HELP. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE MATTER THAT I LIKE HEALTH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS HE AND
JIM DISAPPOINTING AND WE URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION TMG
PARTNERS SB AT HOME BAY AREA
COUNCIL CAN HELP PROPERTIES AND
THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE ON
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM FOR
CONSOLIDATING. TO NEXT WEEK- I
NEED TWO HUNDRED SIX YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KIMBERLY DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK- I KNOW ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE
IT UP. GOOD EVENING PAYER
MEMBERS PAIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN
INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MATH PROFESSOR NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. IN LINE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE IF I COULD OPEN.
AND. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE.
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMIC COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THEIR LINE. THANK YOU. IN
LIGHT TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
YOUR MIKE IS UP. MISTER
CHAIRMAN REPAIRING A LOT OF
OPEN SHOTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MA'AM WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE QUEUE IT. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
RIGHT- ARE QUESTIONS THE
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OUR MOTION BY GABRIEL A SECOND
BY KALRA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO GO
AHEAD IN- CLOSE IF YOU WISH
PREFIGURE EVOKE. ALL RIGHT-
MADAM CHAIRMAN GORDON PLEASE
UNFOLLOW MOTION MOTION TO
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TRUE I. I'D
SAY ARE STILL NOT VOTING.
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY. HI I'M BORED
MAIENSCHEIN. THANKS SILVA HI.
WICKS HI HI. FIFTY FOUR FIVE
ZERO THANK YOU THE BILL PASSES
COLLEGE APPRECIATE EVERYONE
COMING BACK HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET
EVERYONE ON YOUR PLANES
RELATIVELY SOON LET'S GO
THROUGH THE FULL AGENDA
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT ITEM
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TWENTY ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
MAIENSCHEIN DIGITS HI THIS IS A
CONSENT AGENDA. WICKS HI WICKS
I. EIGHT TWO ZERO THANK YOU
LET'S GO IN ORDER FILE ITEM ONE
AB SIXTY EIGHT SALAS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY. KILEY I.
MAIENSCHEIN THANKS FIVE FIVE
WEEKS WEEKS BY. I HAVE. SEVEN
ZERO HI LEARN TO AB ELEVEN ONE
ONE FIVE BLOOM- STUDIES
COMPLETE SERVE WE HAVE FIVE-
ZERO FIVE FIVE TWO TWO. ONE
MEMBER NONVOTING THANK YOU FOR
ONE THREE EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE BLOWN. GABRIELLE APRIL HI
MAIENSCHEIN. WICKS WICKS HI
THERE WILL BE. FIVE TWO ZERO
WITH THREE MEMBERS NINE FORTY
THANK YOU FOR CALLING FOR AB
EIGHT THIRTY TWO PM. GABRIELLE
APRIL I MAIENSCHEIN THANKS NINE
FIVE WEEKS WEEKS I EIGHT TWO
ZERO. FIRST OF. FILE IN FIVE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT BLOOM.
GABRIELLE CAMBIA I. FILEY.
ALLEN. FIVE THIRTY NINE PM
EIGHT I BELIEVE. I'M SO SORRY
THAT WAS NOT. MFL NOTE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN FIVE
WEEKS TIME WICKS I. SIX FIFTY
SIX TWO TWO THANK YOU FILE ITEM
SIX A. B. TWO FIFTY EIGHT THE
OPRAH YOUR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. IN CHINA I WICKS
WICKS. FIVE EIGHT ZERO. FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB FIVE TWELVE
HOLDEN MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I. WICKS WICKS FIVE EIGHT TWO
ZERO HELLO MATE AB FIVE SEVENTY
ONE MAYES. MAIENSCHEIN IN
FRANCE FIVE WEEKS FIVE WEEKS.
FIVE EIGHT TWO ZERO FOUR NINE
NINE SB SIX THIRTY FOUR CARILLO.
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN **** I-
WICKS TIME WICKS I. B. ONE TWO
SIX SIX TWO TWO. ALLENTOWN AB
SEVENTY SEVEN GABRIEL. NUMBER
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I WEEKS
WEEKS FIVE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE
ITEM LEVIN AB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
GABRIEL. SEATTLE. I AM NUMBER
ELEVEN YES HI. HI FEBRUARY
SHARED BY- WICKS WICKS. FIVE
EIGHT ZERO. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
NINETY NINE GABRIEL.
MAIENSCHEIN. WICKS WICKS. FIVE
THREE FOUR SIX TWO ZERO WITH
TWO MEMBERS NOT VOTING. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB EIGHT OH THREE
BOERNER HORVATH. KILEY. FIVE
EIGHT FIVE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN FIVE WEEKS WEEKS
FIVE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB EIGHT THREE FREEMAN
AND MARY MAIENSCHEIN HI. SIXTY
TWO. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
EIGHT THREE EIGHT FRIEDMAN. I
JUST START FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY
SEVEN MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. THANK
MAIENSCHEIN I EIGHT TWO ZERO
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB TEN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY NINE MULLIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIELLE
GABRIELLE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN FIVE WEEKS WICKS I.
A. B. FOUR FIVE SIX SIX OKAY.
TEN TWENTY NINE ON THE
GRANDSTAND CORRECT SORRY NOT NO
NO THAT'S OKAY YES I THINK I
THINK WE HAVE. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX YES THIS ONE-
NOPE AND ONE NON VOTING. THIS
IS MARK CORRECT. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. GRAYSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY ARE TOO HI
THERE I REMEMBER WICKS HI WICKS
I KNOW WOULD BE EIGHT TWO ZERO
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN
POSTPONED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR. MAIENSCHEIN
SANTIAGO HE SAID THE APPLE
THIRTEEN OH FOUR. THE CHAIN I
WICKS WICKS I. SIX TWO ZERO
WITH TWO MEMBERS NON BORING.
AND I THINK FILE ITEM TWENTY
YOU HAVE RECORDED VOTES FOR ONE-
I THINK THAT IS COMPLETELY FAIR
I HAVE- FIVE. THE YESES AND NOS
ZERO KNOWS AND THREE MEMBERS
NOT VOTING GROUP I'M FOLLOWING
TWENTY TWO AGAIN HAS BEEN
POSTPONED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THAT FOCUS.
ENJOY YOUR WEEKEND GET TO THE
AIRPORT. OKAY.